et oui tu bonsoir à tous et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau match de ce pitch est
c'est un match féminin a speech est
féminin aujourd'hui de nouveau le retour
du speech est féminin qui nous avait
offert un très beau match c'était
c'était jeudi si je ne m'abuse qu'on a
vu ce super match entre kosteniuk et
daniela et continue entre l'agglo et et
danielian et aujourd'hui on se retrouve
pour le deuxième match deuxième match
des mal de speechless avec le match
kosteniuk contre that all tire donc
joueuse américaine et on va on va on
peut voir on va un peu voir ce que ça
donne c'est match intéressant match de
premier tour match match de premier tour
j'ai envie de dire alors je vais juste
vérifier que tout soit bien lancée je
vais mettre tout simplement ce que
j'oublie ce que j'ai oublié de faire la
dernière fois je vais le faire tout de
suite pendant que j'y pense parce qu'on
peut le faire que quand le live est
lancé c'est mettre le le austin sur la
chaîne bitstream est comme ça au passage
je vais réussir à voir que ça marche
voire labitrie les berges vous héberge
maintenant donc c'est que ça marche et
d'ailleurs je m'entends maintenant du
coup en arrière parce que j'avais mis la
chaîne devant là pour vérifier donc ça
c'est une bonne chose de faite je vais
aller suivre les joueuses je vais aller
suivre les joueuses
il faut que je trouve leur pseudo alors
kosteniuk ça doit être donc je trouve
leur pseudo faut que je trouve leur
pseudo pourtant j'ai déjà joué contre
elle il faut que je réussisse à trouver
leur pseudo c'est vrai que ça c'est pas
pratique à chaque fois quand quand quand
les personnes ont leur nom de famille ça
va mais quand elles n'ont pas ça devient
tout de suite plus compliqué à trouver
c'est à kosteniuk non c'est pas ça c
gepa le pseudo là aucun pierre j'irai
voir quand ça commence sur le stream
officiel ce sera écrit james quinn mais
voilà merci à florian flohr je savais
que je connaissais le pseudo mais ça me
revenait pas voilà chess queen et on va
pouvoir on va pouvoir l'observer tech
sera commencée salut à l'ombre de kev
donc laurent flore qui est dans le chat
si vous êtes dans le chatt bitstream
j'ai quand même vous checkez mais faut
aller sur le chat de la chaîne de la
chaîne chaise comme fr c'est quand même
là que ça se passe
noir pas dit que je me rappelle pas
avoir eu l'info elle avait téléphoné à
bla de l'agglo pendant la pause à des
rares fois et j'ai pas réussi à savoir
je crois pas au final au final je crois
pas parce que vlad ne l'a pas dit et
pourtant je lui et je lui ai demandé ce
que j'avais écrit sur facebook qui m'a
pas répondu et après marc en plaine -
hollande lendemain matin mais de quoi tu
parles
j ai écrit un message de type genre pas
mal la correction dans la dans la dans
la trompe hostiou quelque chose comme ça
et je n'avais pas eu de réponse je te
fait que tout soit bien comme il faut je
sais pas si vous avez vu d'ailleurs la
vidéo de ce matin les mecs moi je
demande toujours comme ça en début de
stream puisqu'on commence un peu en
avance pour avoir le temps de de parler
va faire que le truc officiel tout le
studio qui tombe tu peux pas là c'est le
studio qui est en train de tomber
c'est quand même partie aujourd'hui en
c1 match et ça va être costaud nues
contre hatton spire salut française man
l'homme tu es la française alors je fais
quelques blitz ouais j'ai essayé de
baisser ces derniers jours sans stream
et j'arrive pas à monter au dessus de
est ce que je sais c'est arena bullet
vont reprendre c'est pas prévu pour la
saison 4
peut-être pour la saison 5 j'ai essayé
d'agir en ce sens ça pour qu'ils aient
plus d'arena moi j'en proposé trois par
semaine 2 aux rares européens et 11 et
aux horaires américain mais le truc
c'est que sur chasse comme la saison est
très chargé
et donc à les speechs s il ya beaucoup
de pitch est en fait cette année
personnellement ça tiendrait qu'à moi je
trouve que les arénas c'est plus marrant
mais après c'est pas moi qui décide et
donc vu que c'est pas moi qui décide
alors on va voir si on est bien par
rapport aux autres uc officiel je vais
essayer de me bien le cadrer
je vais essayer de bien cadrer parce
qu'en fait le stream officiel tu peux tu
peux pas le
tu ne peux fondamentalement pas le cadre
est parfaitement et là je pense qu'on
est bon mais en fait ça des cadres quand
le stream commence j'imagine que c'est
ça on verra bien quand ça commence
les arénas la flèche title tuesday when
nombre de cas mais c'est qu'une fois par
mois le title tuesday et du coup c'est
un tournoi pour les gens qui se trompent
pas jallet dont j'ai déjà donné mon
point de vue sur l'état sur le title tu
faisais moi j'avais plus très envie de
le jouer c'est vrai qu'il vaut mieux
c'est mozart en colère a ouai c'est toi
qui m'a écrit un mail je peux rien y
faire un pour ton pseudo
malheureusement je peux essayer de
demander mais normalement c'est pas trop
mal je m'occupe pas trop de ça les trucs
techniques et où je m'en occupe pas du
tout mais alors pas du tout chez pas du
tout
c'est annie dual le mieux c'est quand
même de refaire un pseudo dans ces cas
là je pense après peut-être que tu tiens
vraiment à garder le même content mais
je pense qu'il imite ça parce que si
tout le monde changer de compte tout le
temps ce sera un problème peut-être pour
leurs bases de données je ne sais pas
quand je dis ça j'en sais rien c'est un
point qui est codé le site j'ai aucune
idée de comment ça marche mais mais
c'est c'est une supposition
donc quoi la vidéo de ce matin j'ai
trouvé pas mal je fait ce matin à 6h un
fou je me suis levé à 6 heures pour
faire de cette vidéo
parce que sinon entre le speech as
aujourd'hui est ce que j'ai à faire
demain j'aurai j'aurais pas eu le temps
de jeu aurait pas eu le temps de deux de
faire de faire quoi que ce soit alors on
va je vais voir si ça commence et je
crois pas je met un petit refresh et je
vais mettre là dessus on est pas mal
les deux joueuses sont installés pour
moi kosteniuk et quand même favori elle
joue souvent sur internet elle est
vraiment forte en blitz
elle est expérimentée en bulles est donc
pour moi que c'était nuke et favori du
match après ça vaut ce que ça vaut
ça vaut ce que ça vaut
on verra bien on verra bien
ils ont la petite prédiction qui
s'affiche moi j'ai du mal à lire parce
que du coup j'ai l'écran petit et je
peux pas le maximiser sous peine de vous
le faire disparaître
c'est un art udall faisceau picot qui
commentent en anglais donc si vous
voulez voir un commentaire féminin et
j'ai envie de dire vous pouvez aller sur
la chaîne de chess comme officiel et
vous aurez un commentaire vous aurez un
match 100% féminin deux filles qui
jouent deux filles qui commente
est-ce que je suis déjà allé aux états
unis voir les bureaux de chasse comme
non non jamais jamais jamais peut-être
un jour mais on n'a pas vraiment
l'utilité
alors je vais je vérifier parce que j'ai
peur que ça commence sans moi en fait
c'est pour ça que je checke autant
regrette le truc comme je peux pas faut
la jouer je sais pas pourquoi j'ai un
passé un bug c'est parce que j'ai un
compte spécial staff mais je peux pas je
peux pas mettre le follow sur les
joueurs
je peux mettre que les jumelles donc en
fait il faut pas que je me fasse faut
pas que je me fasse savoir quoi c'est ça
le truc c'est ça qui me fait peur ça qui
me fait peur
c'est ça qui me fait peur c'est de me
faire avoir salu agro bowser réaliste
uvale aux usa je peux peut-être théberge
et wej et merci beaucoup mais j'ai pas
vraiment le projet pour le moment
d'aller aux usa c'est pas vraiment c'est
pas vraiment dans mon plan à court terme
je suis sûr que je vais réussir à rater
le début du match je le sens on sature
pas commencé et les 18h03 je sais pas
pourquoi ça commence pas ça papote ça
papote pourtant les deux joueuses on les
voit bien à l'écran elles sont là elles
sont assises sais pas trop pourquoi nous
at on dit requis un truc vert sait pas
trop ce que c'est il remonte le vélo de
kosteniuk 2546 qui a l'escrimeuse
attention nous ont mis comme un point
fort de joux est actif et comme point
faible de paga décomposeurs c'est son
sang-froid peut-être ouais c'est vrai
peut-être je sais pas
elle m'a l'air en blitz en tout cas
d'être d'être très solide
elle avait été championne du monde pour
moi c'est la grande favorite du match
quand même l'habitude l'habitude de la
2d l'habitude du stream donc l'habitude
des tournois long des arénas des machins
elle joue en bullet aussi je la sens moi
je la sens favori que les mecs je la
sens favorite
je peux vous lâchez les atomes ce qui
aurait donc là c'est vrai que 25 et sa
démarche allez on va on va récupérer la
partie alors pourquoi est-ce que la
gelée pas mais ça a démarré c'est sûr
voilà c'est bon c'est bon j'ai réussi à
mettre le follow et c'est parti
directement alors on va repassé début de
la partie donc on démarre avec le 5 + 1
et on démarre avec un double fiant kétou
c'est marrant parce que je parlais de ça
avec fable tout à l'heure au téléphone
et je disais que j'avais beaucoup de mal
à jouer cette position avec les noirs
que j'étais pas terrible terrible c'est
ça s'est-il de position à personne j'ai
beaucoup de mal
parce que je trouve qu'avec les noirs on
a on est un peu un tout petit peu moins
bien on a un tout petit peu resserré et
je perds je comprends pas vraiment la
position mais j'ai du mal j'ai du mal à
jouer parce que je la ressens quand et
entreprenant avec les noirs dans cette
position là tu peux te retrouver ce côté
l'udc avec les blancs tu peux te
retrouver un peu pas tu te fait contrer
quoi t'as pas les pièces pour être actif
et pour mener le jeu tu as les pièces un
peu moins bien placé on voit que le four
b2 pour vraiment faire la comparaison
est mieux placé que le fou aux 7,1 il
tape quand même quand le centre s'ouvre
sur le rock
je met du rouge ici et d'un autre côté
on voit que le fou là si on fait b6 fou
bessette on va avoir quelques temps de
retard donc avec les dents on est en un
léger léger - s'il doit pas grand chose
si on joue bien mais mais savent qu'il
faut bien jouer et que moi c'est pas du
tout le type de position qui me
conviennent disons que quand on joue les
slaves on peut on peut on peut être
actif tu vois on peut dans les semis
staff classique on va dire tu joues pour
ses 5 tu joues pour 5 tu joues pour tu
actives et là en fait que tu crées des
échanges t'essayes d'ouvrir le jeu mais
tout d'un coup tu as le fou j'ai deux
kits marche dessus
si tu prends des katja la dame qui prend
si tu fais au sein qu'on l'a vécu en
france et si on prend fou prend 1,5
en fait tous les coups actifs pour les
noirs aide les blancs là il l échange
mais du coup on voit que l'ouverture du
jeu et ça favorise un poil et blanc qui
ont bien la dame en d4 centraliser le
fou en g2 qui t'a bien sûr la diagonale
le fou en b2 aussi et c'est un peu
désagréable on va déjà les blancs mon
avis un peu mieux après
après qui sait peut-être c'est jamais
très grave mais je vous dis ses
positions que j'ai beaucoup de mal à
sentir j'ai du mal être les bons coups
life un assist pour réussir peut-être à
jouer des cinq mais quand bien même la
dame pourra partir alors les blancs
savaient qu'ils ont calé b1 qui est pas
sorti mail le mend c3 sur b5 j'imagine
qu'elle veut jouer tam quelque part
parle d'un match 4 mètres une tour en
derniers tours en c1 et je trouve pas
vraiment pour moi c'est un cauchemar à
jouer c'est avec les noirs j'ai du mal
contre eux contre ces systèmes à double
fioretto du coup pharma va proposer une
variante qui va faire que j'apprenne
parker elle joue les bons coups à
anaëlle mais là tu vas ajouté saint
calais mais la tour en ascète ces genres
de coucou moi j'ai beaucoup de mal à
trouver et elle va réussir quand même à
plus ou moins finir son développement
mais bah du coup c'est moi qui vais qui
vais prendre un cours d'échecs tati ça
joue beaucoup ses positions là ça
amènera peut-être à a progressé à mieux
jouer les blancs qui ont toujours ce
petit plus d'activité mais moins ya
pièces sur l'échiquier moins ça se
ressent là maintenant peut-être un coup
comme dan des huit têtes un enchaînement
coup comme dam des huit tours c'est 8
pour clôturer le développement tu sais
pas si ça se joue elle le joue au hockey
mais le à 6b cinq tours à 7 tours 17
c'était très bien trouvée alors des
noces qui nous dit pousser les pions
côté droit pour les blancs ça sans
visage malgré les dames sur le plateau
ouais ça peut s'envisager danos
cependant le jeu des blancs ils poussent
et poussent plutôt de ce côté là parce
qu'on sent que le surplus d'activité et
les faiblesses elles sont là c'est ses
deux pions et donc on veut plutôt jouer
à zelda mais sur notre point fort donc
là les pièces qui s'échangent mais les
noirs qui reste toujours un peu en
difficulté là les blancs encore la
menace de tours c'est cette fouille
bessette par exemple qui reste donc il
va falloir régler ce problème un coup
comme fou des six paraît pas jouable à
cause de tour d un elfe et tours s'est
mit donc là surtout prend fou prend
j'imagine que surtout reprend fou prend
le fou contrôlera le pion à 6 et on va
réussir à complètement égaliser ou pas
encore
voilà on doit pouvoir faire un truc
quand même 6 e 5 et ramener le roi a eu
et si on arrive à faire ça ou m6 ou d
ici 3 e set peut-être fou ces cinq
échecs qui est possible quelque part et
mettre le fond ans et 5 de toute façon
le roi blanc qui va monter vers 4 mai le
roi noir qui va aller vers des 6 et ça
devrait être
ça devrait tenir pour les noirs pour moi
ça tombe virtuelle a fait une grosse
partie celle à faire un truc que moi je
personnes personnellement incapable de
faire donc forcément gros respect quand
t'es pas capable c'est toujours
impressionnant suite vous il très très
bien joué elle a réussi à tenir une
position que j'aurais pas j'aurais pas
pu tenir personnellement donc la loi qui
va arriver vers des 6 et ça va ça va
aller on va échanger ans à 4 avec les
noirs le fou ces huit tiens tiens un
pion à 6 pense pas que les blancs puisse
vraiment pressé peut-être un coup comme
fou 17 ici est jouable mais bon elle fut
roi des six beaucoup plus fort à mon
avis est fou 17 maintenant et c'est
peut-être même les noirs qui vont avoir
un poil d'activité puisque sur à 5 de
leur fougue et 4 qui gagne le pion donc
et blanc ont peut-être devoir jouer fous
ces deux et un coup comme fou ces six
échecs et peut-être envisageable avec
l'idée sur quatre de faire f 5
ouais ça peut être intéressant parce que
plus on prend fou prend il y aura foule
prend à 4 donc ça ça pourrait gagner un
pion c afp le roi va devoir partir vers
g3 et comme souvent quand on réussit à
repousser les l'aller menace adverse
c'est toi qui pressent un tout petit peu
après c'est plus symbolique qu'autre
chose mais ouvrages et 3 semblent plus
ou moins forcée elle a fait 4
alors je comprend pas trop ce qui se
passait sur f5 honnêtement je vais juste
mettre un petit coup d'ordi charles
sokhiev saraya epyon g7 en l'air pardon
pardon pardon c'est faute de ma part f5
marché par cette excuse est moins bon
donc c'est juste complètement égal j'ai
oublié le pion g7 ça arrive façon ça
sent la position égale donc ça ça se
passe bien pour les deux joueuses d'aia
mur de pions contenir deux pions
pression est quasi symétriques
il ya f5 maintenant alors comment est ce
que les blancs sauvent leurs pions bah
voilà ils font à 5
parce que le fou est venu en c3 donc
maintenant à cinq est possible mon avis
ça va échanger massivement en quatre
parce que les noirs vont être contents
ils vont garder des pions assure blanc
et ça va probablement faire un nul à ce
moment là fait recette
elle tient le statu quo
ouais c'est vrai que les blancs peuvent
pas bouger le roi h5
ok c'est vrai qu'elle garde ce petit
conflit là si on prend qui on prend les
devants de façon peut faire foot est roi
fou des zfu ces deux et je vois pas
vraiment comment les comment les noirs
progresse le roi va pas pouvoir partir
sous peine de se prendre ou g7 fou prend
1,6 si le fou pas en fuite pour éviter
ça on pourra remettre laurent trois fois
en d4 donc là ça semble devoir répéter
mais c'est vrai que voilà le genre de
final pourquoi pas les jouer un petit
peu x 7 alors si on veut presser avec
les blancs est ce qu'on peut faire
quelque chose dans ma rien on peut pas
monter droit de toute façon on peut pas
monter le roi je vois pas trop haut
qu'elle veut mettre le fou en d6
pourquoi pas mais maintenant sur tout
mais si ça fou prend et ça va chercher
le fion b donc c'est pas possible il
faut 5 elle veut jouer au fou j'ai cette
3ème set c'est le surnom fois à cette
norme à la raison mettre la pression
parce que j'ai trouvé quatre bien jouer
fossé s'est tu quand même parce que
c'est vrai que les noirs se met mal
autant elle a du mal à jouer vital a du
mal à défendre vite ça pourrait coûter
maintenant peut-être fou b6 afu b6 fou
prend pions prend et roy e set et le
problème c'est qu'il va y avoir le temps
de de faire peut-être trois des six
quoique peut-être autant prêt ya pas le
temps ok c'est pas mal joué de la part
des blancs qui crée un vrai problème
croît de 3 est maintenant sur wuala et
maintenant il faut prendre quatre ok
mais faut prendre ou à prendre wade 6
b737 3e 5 à 5
roy prend aussi sa 4 ème 5 à 3 f 6 à 2 f
sept des huit dames échec
peut-être faire des huit dames en
premier roi prend des 8es elle va
réussir à prendre à 6 mais elle pourra
pas parce qu'il ya damas six échecs
mais peut-être que ces prêts sable
encore pour les blancs peut-être un coup
comme dame c5 ou d'amd 6 dan 17 pour
chasser nos rois f7 je pense qu'elle va
gagner avec les blancs elle va faire
froid g7 elle va réussir encaissé le
pion h la dame prend achi c'est jouable
un échange des dames gagne donc elle va
pouvoir encaisser le pion elle va la
gagner
ouais elle va réussir à faire rage sept
rois suit 1
il faudrait qu elle m laurent g7 alors
là ça sent pas bon
enfin quoique si le roi revient à f la
finale de seront nulles d'alger cinq
échecs roi 8 dames 5 échecs croix et
fluide j'imagine donc elle commence par
dame j'ai 6 mai 3e set bien joué
dame prend roi prend c'est nul le roi
est bien placé elle fait dame g7 les
changes est pas possible elle va faire
h6 imagine mesdames f8 échecs dames
ok je pensais qu'elle feu dame g8 dame
f5 ici jouable on ça c'est bien joué
d'alger 8h cette dame f6 d'alger cette
contrée chèques qu'elle fait comme ça
ouais le truc c'est qu'il ya le clouage
s'est bien défendue de la part des noirs
on peut pas il va falloir tenter dame g8
ici elle a fait nul elle aurait pu
tenter dame g8 quand même et jouer pour
h7 à lattes as tu peur de se prendre un
match ou un truc comme ça il y avait
peut-être matière à faire des pièges
sais pas j'ai pas mis leur dis donc
duras tueur à dire exactement mais mais
en gros les noirs qui ont bien réagi qui
ont ramené le roi mais c'est un peu
inquiétant pour anna parce que c'est
vrai qu'il est beaucoup plus lente et
elle s'est fait mettre sous pression dès
la première partie après elle a bien
tenu bon
c'est pas un c'est pas clair clair qu'on
nous dit dans le chat il ya beaucoup de
rendez-vous à suivre sur la chaîne de
chasse aux bonnes affaires cette année
il va y avoir aussi les trois grands
prix il va y avoir les trois grands prix
sur sur la chaîne chasse com/fr donc le
grand prix fidh de urrma et les deux
autres grands prix fille tu crois qu'il
y en a un à tel-aviv et l'autre à
hambourg
donc ce sera en juillet novembre et
décembre donc ça c'est sûr que ce sera
suivi avec maxime qui jouera pour se
qualifier pour les candidats et on
suivra aussi très probablement mais
c'est pas encore officielle la coupe du
monde fidh donc la coupe du monde fidh
qui sera qui sera aussi suivie en direct
avec là encore deux places pour réussir
à se qualifier pour les candidats encore
tout vérifié c'était l'année dernière
les deux places et ce qu'ils n'ont pas
changé je vérifierai tout ça mais de
mémoire ça c'est resté deux places donc
on suivra ces événements qui seront les
événements phares de l'année ainsi que
le championnat du monde 960 qui sera là
aussi sur la chaîne de chasse comme fr
donc énormément d'événements sur cette
chaîne n'hésitez pas à follow histoire
d'avoir tout lé toutes les notifications
et mais de toute façon vous pouvez aussi
enfin compris que vous n'avez pas
notification mais j'essaye si j'oublie
pas de toujours mettre les les veaux
sting sur la chaîne du stream comme ça
si vous laissez l'onglet twitch point tv
se lâche enfin thales lâche bitstream
ouvert vous avez vous avez normalement
des clashs end chasse comme fr passe en
ligne vous avez l'hébergement et donc ça
vous permet d'être sûr de ne pas rater
ces événements est le premier grand prix
de l'année qu'on suivra normalement avec
avec l'homme que l'on nomme vlad
donc ce sera un gros un gros un gros
tournoi avec avec du gros commentaire
donc on est passé un petit peu vite
cette ouverture par un peu vite
eux ils l'ont joué mais nous on n'a pas
trop vu donc c'était
c'est entrer dans un grand vide à
m'accepter donc là ça ressemble de
nouveau à des structures de type slave
et ça c'est vrai que côté new qui est
une joueuse active par exemple savons
aussi c'est un truc que j'arrive mieux à
jouer parce que là on peut jouer de
manière quand je parlais des différences
un peu entre la position qu'on avait
avant il fallait réussir à rien faire et
à bien défendre
là avec les noirs on voit qu'on est un
peu comprimés mais on a des idées
offensives cash 5 avaler f4 le fou qui
peut revenir en c5 pour taper peut-être
du tour 8 f 5 pourquoi pas ou g6 f5 et
c'est tout c'est eux quatre renforts
s'en prendre aux pions des cinq les
noirs ont un jeu plutôt plutôt plutôt
actif plutôt non pas offensive parce que
c'est pas le mot mais on est comprimé
mais on n'est plus à un élastique on va
dire que dans la première partie avec
les noirs c'est plutôt un roseau celle
que levante souffle dessus tu plie mais
ne rompt pas et là tu es plutôt un
élastique
tu es un peu resserré métal idée de très
vite à jouer le jeu un jouet pour du f5
jouer pour de l'attak après le danger
c'est que si les blancs tu comprime
c'est d'autant plus embêtant
donc les blancs qui ont mis un fonds hi5
à valiant h4 et le fou de noir qui est
revenu dans ses 5 qui est vraiment bien
placé parce qu'ils tapent sur le pion f2
donc ça peut ça peut ça peut un jour
être un problème si la colonne f s'ouvre
pour le moment c'est du jeu c'est du jeu
intéressant temps du roi h1 ce que les
blancs peuvent vouloir eux mêmes jouets
h et f 4 attention tout de même un parce
qu'on se retrouve maintenant dans le
viseur du fou le fouillant des quatre
qui s'en prend aux cavaliers le cavaly
qui protège le sens donc c'est vrai
qu'un jour il ya 5 arrive et on peut re
se retrouve avec le roi mal placée avec
les blancs il faut trouver de la
stabilité et faire attention de ne pas
avoir pris trop d'espacé se faire
contrer peut aussi avoir des c6 pour
échanger déjà le pion des cinq puis
après sans prendre option de 4 avec le
roi en ligne de mire
forcément comme je joue ce genre de
position avec les noirs j'ai plus
tendance à aimer avec les noirs mais ça
veut rien dire donc le cavalier qui
revient en f3 pour s'en prendre aux
foules cavaliers c5 l'idée c'est que sur
cavaliers prend elle voulait faire pions
prend et attaquer le cavalier s'en
prendre à eux quatre fous ces deux là
qui des cavaliers prend qui on prend
tout reprend mais attention parce que
c'est peut-être pas grand-chose
grand-chose cette menace là et peut-être
que les noirs peuvent envoyer le coin f5
ici
finalement qui est un peu à double
tranchant ça donne des cases
donc elle prend ses trois ans premier
qui on prend et peut-être f5 maintenant
mais il ya eu 5 qui peut rester en prise
en fin de variantes à fo calculé skipper
du pion prend et du pion aux 5 tours 8
bien joué ça des clous lecavalier qui
étaient cloués ça enlève et ça protège
le pion eux qui peut être menacée dans
la variante f5 pour les noirs alors là
les blancs qui ont la paire de fou et la
paire de fou et c'est tout comme
avantages à long terme est un peu des
spasmes et l'espace comme je disais
c'est un peu à double tranchant encore
que si on réussit à le conserver
ça peut être pas mal alors à cinq prises
des spas sallèles dame honnêtement ça
menace rien puisque sur pions prend on
fera pions prend et avec les normes on
est peut-être heureux mais auquel fait
b5 qui est pas idiot non plus ses c4 et
peut-être elle va jouer des quatre pour
se créer un pion passé mais le pion
pourrait être rapidement intercepté
attaquer donc pas sûr que ce soit le
coup décidé par les noirs c'est un autre
côté si elle prend dame prend les blancs
vont être plutôt contents de trouver de
l'activité sur la colonne c est
notamment ce cavalier qui pourrait
déstabiliser donc d4 serait quand même
le coup le but logique sinon faut
s'activer vite fait faire du f 5 qui est
jouée sur toute la largeur de
l'échiquier soit l'un soit l'autre je
pense pas qu'avec les enfants puissent
bon puis se permet ou alors baisser puis
f5
mais on va pas pouvoir se permettre
d'attendre maintenant faut vraiment
faire l'élastique faut vraiment pour les
noirs réussir à envoyer l'élastique et à
attaquer les blancs à s'en prendre à la
joueuse adverse sous peine
sous peine de se faire bouffer par
l'espace donc on prend ces cas du majin
dame prend je vois pas de
contre-indication 9,5 sera pas jouable
directement à cause d'eux des six donc
elle fait d'anne decis mais là peut-être
un petit coup comme tour c'est un métier
de fer fou b1 s'en prendre aux cavaliers
il ya pions derrière six et sept tombes
c'est chaud pour ces inquié clairement
pas un coup il ou elle fera sûrement
tour s'est vite on peut aussi faire
tourner ses seins pour être lautour en
b1 et faire du fou est roi où jouer
tourbe et indirects fous ces 8
ok le foot il veut repartir vers g4 ça
c'est très bien joué de la part de
kosteniuk qui joue ce coût à tempo et
qui repart avec le fou de l'autre côté
ouais c'est pas c'est pas mal joué du
tout se fout c'est 8 peut-être un coup
comme moi j'ai deux pour pour colmater
un peu de l'espace et surtout j'ai
quatre fers à je crois qu'elle fait qu'à
et des deux qui est une autre option
assez intelligente puisqu'elle veut
faire f3 le cas échéant et enfin en cas
en cas de souci et le cavalier qui peut
rebondir ok maintenant f5 qui part donc
elle fait cette prise d espace foot roi
lecavalier a attaqué elle va sûrement
repartir vers 17 le pur f5 et défendu
par le cavalier donc elle peut passer
devant et après jouer pour cavaliers
apsys c'est chose faite d'un coup comme
x 4 est peut être envisageable sais je
sais jouer pardon ça cool cavaliers
peut-être on prépare du fou c6 qui
enfermerait la tour on peut avec les ans
décidé de donner la tour à 8 ans blitz
et jouer l attaque à fond un
probablement partie longue c'est un peu
un peu osé mais en blitz finalement
c'est pas si idiot parce que si pour
sauver cette tour on peut jouer poussé
sous b79 bessette on peut pas à la fois
fou prend donc on peut faire cavalier
fils et donner une qualité mais j'ai
l'impression que ça fait qu'alexis est
content de la qualité on va voir 0
activités donc peut-être il faut faire
le deuil de la tour tour des huit pouces
et 6
yaya toure b8 encore surtout ses six la
tour n'est pas encore perdue j'avais
j'avais oublié que lecavalier défendez
au cas en cas de déclin a donc ça tient
encore mais j'ai l'impression qu'ils
aient une tactique qui marchent genre ok
je me demandais si on pouvait faire je
sais pas si ça marchait remet un truc un
peu dans ce style là pouvait être
intéressant pour déloger la dame mais
bon d'un même si c'est des six échecs
peut-être genre de choses comme ça
pouvait pouvait fonctionner mais
peut-être fou aussi c'est sûr pions
prend c'est cette france et 4 et la tour
était défendue donc on pouvait pas
conserver la dame enfin en tout cas
c'était une variante possible et
envisageable
elle a fait dams et 6 pour échanger des
dames et tour ses huit donc ça assez
logique car elle veut se remettre la
structure dans l'ordre mais cavaliers c4
elle va forcer à il peut pas y avoir des
changes parce que sur pions prend
lecavalier serait cloué donc la lune
blanche qui ont une vraie menace c'est
de gagner la dame est cette dame elle va
devoir partir
alors là j'ai dû rater encore un épisode
ok il ya tout reprend qui découvrait le
problème c'est qui encore le pion aux
cinq ans prise donc elle a réussi à
trouver un moyen de semis défendre mais
auquel à ses passes à ses katas sabban
de nabeul elle a sauvé la tour de cette
manière là mais mais la tente où tout va
gagner marquer et prend 1,5
ça va être indéfendable peut encore
tenter cavaliers prendre quatre
peut-être on va perdre cinq cas le fou
qui va venir en b3 sur échec
peut-être 3 et fuite mais aurait fuité a
peut-être fouache 6
on va être cloué de partout mais mais
bon ok four b3 échec non f4 elle
maintient cavalier va faire flouer faut
aussi ce résistant un kosteniuk vraiment
belle défense de la part des noirs sa
tenue sur un fil ça donnerait
l'impression que que les blancs auraient
une tactique pour finir le job mais elle
n'a pas forcément trouvé maintenant il
ya peut-être qualifié cinq échecs cavale
et prend 1,4 la découverte le
ge qui est passé et les blancs qui se
retrouve avec une pièce devant une
position complètement foutu alors ici
j'ai vraiment l'impression qu'après dame
français si sa position était très
avantageuse pour les blancs mais y'avait
rien qui gagnait direct donc la question
est pour le moment j'ai l'impression que
hatton ce qui rejoue un petit peu mieux
mais la pendule est complètement
al'avantage de kosteniuk qui réussi à
jouer plus vite et qu'il a trouvé une
grosse défense avec dame france et 6 je
pensais vraiment qu'il y aurait un truc
qui y gagneraient pour pour les blancs
mais soit y avait rien soit là pas
trouvés j'ai juste eu le temps d'allumer
leur dis quelques secondes il donnait +1
50 + 2 donc j'avais pas de gain direct
ça donne l impression que mais bon elle
a réussi à dévier la torah macha et et à
bien tenir alors qu'elle s'était
vraiment fait dominer elle n'avait pas
réussi à envoyer f5 rapidement donc elle
s'était retrouvée en difficulté en
défense mais ça a tenu donc nouvelle
partie c'est une anglaise et c'est ça et
donc de nouveau un double fiant kétou
pour kosteniuk qui a l'air de bien gérer
ces parties avec les blancs qui a l'air
de bien gérer ces parties avec les
blancs donc là est-ce qu'on joue des 5
avec les noirs pourquoi pas mais ce qui
a une vraiment une vraie contre
indication de ce coup je vois pas
vraiment de découverte gravissime ici le
kava le flux n'est pas protégé si
lecavalier le protège il ya un excellent
père l'a appris ici pris ici et elle a
fait cavaler g4 juste regarder si des
cinq était une option par curiosité des
cinq qui est ce qu'il ya un problème
le cavalier qui arrivait verbe et si
c'était pas terrible non non elle a
beaucoup mieux joué c'est assez bien
joué la sq à la fédé c'est eux des
cavaliers g4 cavale est à 4 elle va
venir récupérer le pion aux 5 n'est
peut-être pas tout de suite elle peut
inter
posez peut-être qu'à rallier 17
qui prend 1,5 elle reprend direct il ya
cavaliers b6 qui est hyper pénible parce
que la tour va se retrouver un peu mal
plaçant à 6 elle va avoir du mal à
revenir en jeu matériellement les noirs
en un pion de plus mais la paire de fou
pour les blancs le pion c5 qui est un
peu faible mais d'un autre côté ouais
c'est quand même qu'ils ont de plus s'il
est noir réussissent à se réorganiser ça
va aller tours à huit
alors comment est ce que les blancs
utilisent leur activité qui a valu à
quatre ça a l'air bon mais que menace
ton vraiment avec les blancs qu'elle est
qu'elle est vraiment notre note notre
idée profonde est ce que c'est de faire
h 4 h 5 peut-être ça peut être une idée
parce que là je vois pas de coup j'ai
l'impression que les coudes attaques
directes sont pas sont pas fous fous
fous à 3 ok on s'en prend à ses cinq
bons blocs le déplacement du cavalier 17
c'est assez bien joué ça comme idée est
sûre b6 du coup on a créé une autre
faiblesse en c6 qui cette fois ci est
bien placé dans le viseur du fou deux
cases blanches et bien dans le viseur du
founan food et 5 e sap a été joué c'est
un miss clic elle revient en b2
maintenant qu'elle a créé
l'affaiblissement entoure ces huit tours
d2 ça va doubler sur la colonne d
et avec les noms on peut aussi faire un
truc genre c4 je sais pas ce que ça vous
rendent le pion et mettre le carillon c5
je pense que c'est un peu osé on sent
peut-être on s'en fiche de données ce
pion de toute façon comme ça si on perd
c'est si c'est pas si important et ses
quatre cavaliers c5 j'ai pas
l'impression que ça offre trop trop
d'activités effectué huit temps d un ça
va être changée j'imagine qu'elle est
noire qui attendent le patricien coup
comme le 4 est possible pour s'en
prendre aux rois h4 moi ça me tente
toujours pour prendre de l'espace
mais bon tu donnes la 4g cadre d'un
autre côté ça lui albator salua sur
obiwi libye et oui on est en quart de
finale donc h4 finalement jouer est le
truc c'est que si tu fais h5 et puis on
prend qui on prends tu rajoutera quand
même une faiblesse
alors h5 quand même très logique
on peut aussi je vois un truc comme tout
reprend tout reprend tout reprend fou
prend 1,5 à vous prendre 5 et dames ces
quatre échecs
c'est ce qu'elle va jouer c'est
exactement ce que je voulais vous vous
proposez
parce que le cavaliere f4 et bien placé
il interdira g7 à cause de cavaliers 6-3
6-7 qui perd à cause de dames 6 3 e 8
il va y avoir un mini madame g 8 échecs
dames prend achète d'un projet 6 d'impro
f5 et on va on va raser tout tout les
leroy ça semble être un gros avantage
pour kosteniuk parce que c'est le seul
coup en fait 38.7 père à cause de dames
6 échecs dames 35 3g cette cavale ie6
est roi et fuite cavalier e 6 dont 3 8
dames g8 dame prend 1,7 à oka la même
dame ci soit encore plus fort moi
j'étais sûr damage cette dame pranger 6e
d'un bref cinq qui gagne aussi 1
mais mesdames si ça gagne la pièce c'est
beaucoup plus simple encore pour
l'emporter toujours difficile quand vous
voyez un gain surtout si c'est pas vous
qui jouez
c'est difficile de voir le deuxième donc
une nouvelle nouveau gambie dame
refusait pourtant on va voir dans quoi
çà çà çà transpose on peut transposer
dans beaucoup de choses donc à jouer 3
elle fait le e3 poison d'axel smith et
ça va retomber ça peut retomber dans un
genre de système cole ou dans une
mayrand alors lamérant la tuque wilb 6
donc ça va pas vraiment retombée dans
une errance avait eu ces six ça aurait
pu donc à jouer qui est aimé des deux
sarres crocs elle va vouloir jouer pour
4 j'imagine donc fou b3 fou b2c comme un
système cole et les blancs qui ont un
petit avantage dans le sens où le fou en
d3 et probablement un peu mieux placé
que le fonds aux 7 et que les blancs
bruns temps de plus donc elle a repris
du cavalier ok ça va prendre pour
reprendre alors est-ce qu'elle reprend
du fou du cavalier
pion ça m'étonnerait quand même c'est
une mauvaise tête du futsal avantage de
contrôler la casse des 5es du cavalier
ça al'avantage de pouvoir sauter vers 5
essais 6 je pense que je voudrais plutôt
prendre du cavalier mais il fallait
calculer dam des cinq si on avait un bon
coup et c'est vrai que peut-être du coup
prendre du fou est pas idiot mais la
composition qui me semble pas forcément
mieux pour pour anna donc elle prend ses
six elle va reprendre peut-être un petit
coup de tours c1 ou dames eux deux ils
détour d un tour c'est un énorme pas le
temps de faire tout retour ces huit
tours c'est cette dame a huit qui peut
être un plan et toute façon je pense que
les blancs réagir et parfois f34 donc
une nouvelle fois ses positions avec
petit plus pour les blancs pourquoi
parce que la position est complètement
symétrique au niveau des pions mais les
pièces blanches sont un peu mieux placé
donc alphée dame b 8
elle veut faire dame bessette et bouger
la tour ans et 8 à savoir que dame
bessette y aura toujours du x 6
donc elle fait cavalier avec 3 pour le
moment d'amener cette fois ci sous
prenait froid je pense on peut reprendre
du pillon et après essayer de jouer pour
moi j'ai un tour g1 et attaquer le roi
ça peut être une option j'imagine ça
peut être une option fois ci souffre un
f3 comprend f3 et jouer pour la colonne
g
moi je serais allé pour ce truc là après
la le temps un bon la foux prendre froid
est vraiment une envisageable parce qu
adam prend maintenant c'est vrai que
pour ce refroidissement juste pour dire
alors est-ce que ce qu'est ce que ça va
aller ça je met un petit coup d'ordi
d'amd 5 et leur dit qu'ils aiment et
bien les blancs ici d'après le coin f4
c'est vrai que le roi noir me paraissait
faible
quoique il aime rimont chansons qui
racontent un peu n'importe quoi
peut-être pas f4 peut-être tour c'est un
plutôt leur dit qu un peu on peut un peu
à la ramasse mais donc c'était c'était
une idée je pense par mois ça m'aurait
intéressé après c'est chacun son style 1
c'est peut-être pas très académiques
alors fois six maintenant et il ya eu
dans ma vie donc elle n'est pas allée
faire [ __ ] en f3 salaire qu'elle
voulait pas jouer avec fu price 3 mais
je crois qu'elles auraient été
contraints sur x 6 direct fait tourner
un prix ce prise mais là ça m'a l'air
d'être égal une nouvelle fois j'ai enfin
pourquoi les blancs serez mieux les
pièces se sont échangées l'activité
s'est plus ou moins égaliser les noirs
qui vont centraliser la dame en d5
là on est une position complètement
symétrique au niveau des pions c'est
exactement les deux mêmes structures qui
se regardent en chiens de faïence et le
placement des pièces et quasi équivalent
donc les blancs qui font qu il faut c
quatre et peut-être que le cavalier
blanc va arriver à eux cinq mais savait
qu'avec da me katz à immobilise le
cavalier et que c'est nous qui va
prendre la nulle ou atone ce qui est en
jeu c'est pas une joueuse a pris là nul
pour le moment toujours plus deux pour
kosteniuk qui semble bien gérer ce début
de match j'ai l'impression qu'en terme
de contenu elle n'est pas au dessus mais
elle a joué un peu plus vite est bon
parfois jouer plus vite c'est quand même
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'important donc il ya eu que 4 5 dans
cette partie là et les noirs qui ont
décidé de jouer la petrov et kosteniuk
qui a joué la ligne avec food et 3 elle
va vouloir dans un deuxième temps mettre
le fou en c2 et jouer avec des 4 donc si
les noirs jouent des cinq des quatre on
va voir un genre de sport ressemblent à
des françaises variantes des changes et
le fou en c2 qui est bien placé parce
qu'ils libèrent la case d3 pour la dame
après sur dam des trois y aura toujours
du fourrage 5-fu g6 et pour le moment le
pion noir qui reste en d6 parce qu'il
veut garder enfin elle veut garder le
contrôle de la casse des cinq donc les
petits développements cavaliers d2 il va
y avoir du cavalier huit cavaliers à 20
kg 6 kg 3 quelque chose comme ça
et les blancs qui vont vouloir jouer h3
pour chasser le fou de cases noires qui
repartirait éventuellement vers le 6 mai
nord kivu ses 6 kg 3 on peut jouer des
cinq et on voit rarement une position
sensiblement symétrique
mais c'est jamais facile le cavalier
blanc arrive en premier en rêve 5 c'est
vrai qu'elle cavalier noir peut pas
avoir cette case f5 c'est la différence
entre le fou aux 7 et le fou ces deux
ans il y en a un qui est actif et
l'autre non et c'est des petites lignes
qui donne des petits avantages c'est pas
mal ce que fait kosteniuk en ce début de
match je trouve qu'elle réussit à
obtenir
un bon nombre de positions comment dire
jouable c'est pas le mot mais elle
obtient un certain nombre de positions
août à août un petit plus avec les
blancs et où tu peu près c est en fait
ce qu'elle fait c'est que elle joue son
petit plus mais elle joue très vite donc
elle passe elle pressent pas vraiment la
position bon si à la presse un peu mais
eux
mais elle presse surtout la pendule en
fait elle fait un peu les deux ailes
elle joue aux échecs alors là vraiment
totale de chez total c'est qu'elle joue
aussi la pendule à la dame va pouvoir
arriver en f3 lecavalier vers f5 c'est
toujours petit avantage au kfc un conte
premier x fuite
peut-être il faut prendre une fois
développé le fou m la dame en f3 et
c'est ce qu'elle est noire doivent être
quasi cassis quasi égaliser mais c'est
légèrement pénible petit répertoire
intéressant de la part de kosteniuk qui
peut qui peut être être heureux qu'au
pied alors que vous voyez en dessous de
moi la question du jour qu'est ce que la
communauté des échecs doit faire pour
aider les échecs féminin à grandir dans
le monde et vous pouvez répondre à la
commission
en twittant avec le hashtag speech elles
ont été listés pas à donner votre
opinion
peut-être c'est le fait d'organiser des
compétitions féminines comme le
financement de chasse comme vous aussi
avoir des avis divergents avec fab on a
souvent parlé sur la chaîne on était
plutôt pour justement enlever les échecs
les 1001 à terme et non pas pas tout de
suite mais que ce soit l'objectif dc dc
plusieurs décennies non sur sûr du vin
30 ans d'horizon mais ça c'était notre
opinion comprenais pas trop pourquoi
mais si je joue ensemble
faire du mixage ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont partisans de faire du mx2 mixte
partout et donc finalement les noirs qui
ont réussi à contrer al a réussi à
mettre le cavalier on veut 4 et voilà
ces genres de position un peu plus
agréable pour les blancs et les noirs là
encore qui font une bonne partie qui ont
bien bien réussi à rester recroquevillé
je dois dire qu'à nage ou bien ce genre
de position où aller après son
répertoire
son répertoire la pousse à les jouer
donc ces quelques elle doit bien aimé
mais elle joue pas mal ses positions où
ella ella ce manque d espace avec une
position symétrique vous faut pas faire
grand chose alors réussi à bien pousser
les pièces de verre c'est là peut-être
là le choix elle peut prendre g3 qui est
intéressant mon qui va doubler les pions
mais les blancs vont obtenir un peu
d'activité avec ses pions peut-être elle
peut prendre en d2 pour prendre la paire
de fou mais les cavalières viendront où
elle peut même jouer des cinq des cinq
je ferai pas je pense mais est ce quand
même intéressant parce que si les blancs
peuvent pas prendre le 4 c'est vrai que
des 5 avec le fou qui revient en d6
lecavalier qui peut venir en aide 4
c'est elle qui pourrait se retrouver
avec l'activité des cinq as et elle a dû
passer du temps à calculer l'histoire de
cavaliers prend le cas tu comprends 4
voir ce qui se passe avec ce pion de 4
et elle a dû considérer qu'elles
pourraient le soutenir facilement avec
f5 en cas de prise prise que pions f
pourrait venir protéger le pion et faire
une avancée donc c'est avec les blancs
peuvent pas prendre le cavalier on a
toujours une position symétrique là
encore plus au niveau de la structure
des pions c'est complètement
complètement symétrique
mais maintenant la première escarmouche
des blancs est passé et c'est au noir de
mettre la pression à noter cependant que
kosteniuk est là où elle met toujours la
pression ça la pendule donc est-ce que
la fin que la gagnante du temps à se
qualifier pour le speech est comme le
vainqueur du junior je ne crois pas ça
me chante là il faut quand même
souligner que je faut que je vérifie
remet gêné j'ai pas j'ai pas souvenir
d'avoir lu ça donc je dirais non
mais a noté que le niveau du speech est
féminin est bien en dessous du niveau du
speech à junior 1 quand même je pense
que ses joueuses là
un peu un peu juste pour lutter avec les
seniors on a vu où les fans qu'ils
avaient pris je crois que c'était 28,2
le score finale contre na cas si c'est
pour pour rejouer naka ou mvl ou quoi et
prendre et prendre 29 ha ha
c'est peut-être mieux d'éviter de jouer
à moins qu'ils aient eu fait les arénas
laly perdure où tu joues narrow dit ce
qu'ils firent ouldja naka et tout ça
c'est déjà pénible mon lacet encore
plusieurs ce que c'est un match contre
un mec comme ça donc c'est encore plus
dur et et si je me compare avec ses
joueurs évidemment ils sont beaucoup
plus fortes que moi en longues sans
aucun doute
cependant on a à peu près le même lots
sur czech comme avec kosteniuk lancement
je crois que j'ai 26 62 ans blitz à la
26 67
donc même si elle joue forcément
beaucoup beaucoup mieux 3 ans longue et
même en blitz sur un vrai échiquier sur
internet on doit sensiblement le même
niveau puisque on a le même vélo ça
reflète quand même quelque chose et
faire un match de trois heures contre
hikaru nakamura tu en mode speech s
personnellement je préférerais pas le
faire
donc je sais pas si ce serait vraiment
un cadeau affaire de donner une
invitation au speech as masculins parce
que c'est vrai que comme comme le match
de willy fans
c'est vrai que si c'est pour se prendre
elle peut faire [ __ ] en f4 et g5 je
pense et ça doit être ni le direct si
c'est pour se prendre un plus en plus 22
c'est un peu chiant à jouer avec apsys
au lieu de g4 peut-être c'était une idée
poli faith prenons ça me chante
l'arrivée bien sûr je ne serais pas ce
serait pas un cadeau qui était truffé g5
le problème c'est que le cavalier peut
arriver h5
pour et combien même mais bon si are you
are 5 ça peut être un peu pénible elle
fait g5 avec les blancs elle va tourner
là elle va faire cavalier f2 ou
cavaliers c1 elle va essayer de ramener
le cavalier par là bas ces quatre quais
mais je pense qu'elle doit ramener le
cavalier là bas parce que de là bas si
lecavalier parents g8 elle pourrait
peut-être sauter vers u6 mais ça fait
pas grand chose
elle atteint un tiers qui est de nouveau
mal autant ses seins qu'elle prend
l'espace t4 elle prend encore de
l'espace maintenant elle va probablement
partir pour ce truc là elle le fait pas
elle part pour bessin québec a troqué
ses pas mais elle a joué à un jeu
complètement aal.l dames et elle va
réussir à mettre le roi en d4 et ça va
être une vraie pression en réalité parce
qu'il peut y avoir des occasions qu'il
peut y avoir des trucs qu'on n'y a plus
on prend ces sites qui marchent aussi
puisqu'elle va gagner le pion des 5 vous
avez l'embarras du choix je pense que
roi des quatre pour préparer et essayer
de jouer sur des zouk sanguin était bon
aussi
ok la a5 que j'avais pas vu à 5 qui
défendent et je pense qu'elle a raté
aussi sinon on n'aurait pas joué comme
ça et maintenant les noirs qui voir qui
a valu au sahel va peut-être contré je
sais pas s'il y avait six avaient roi
des cadres d'abord c'est vrai qu'à
s'inquiétait pas possible du coup
puisqu'ils avaient la prise en passant
est peut-être que ça ça gagner en dur à
dire qu'à 5 c'est vrai que c'est un coût
qui était dur à voir parce que le pion
il disparaît et maintenant je pense que
c'est même au blanc de faire gaffe parce
que cavalia 5 et pranger 4 ça arrive
vite
c'est vous qui l'avez pas vu ouais après
je sais pas assez des fois talentueux
c'est difficile dans ces positions l'a
surtout quand tu commandes des fois tu à
l'intuition d'un coup quoi tu te dis je
n'ai pas à baisser en premier ça sent le
truc qui va pas forcément fonctionner
les rois des quatre kf3 échec ici je
pense roi ou trois qui a gagné 1,5
donc il faut partir en c3 maintenant non
mais faut pas faire nul à l'autre à 4
secondes
non mais t'as pas le droit de jouer nul
ici incroyable elle n'a pas voulu
prendre le risque de d'aller prendre à 5
et de créer un pion pas s'éloigner
j'aurais quand même pris le risque y
avait je pense pas qu'elle était
perdable est en fait l'adversaire avec
3.7 secondes
il ya qu une seconde de rajouts avec les
cavaliers ah oui il faut savoir aussi un
petit truc c'est que les cavaliers sont
les pièces les plus difficiles à jouer
en en bullet parce que le chemin est
plus difficile à faire c'est plus
difficile à faire en fait tout
simplement c'est plus difficile à faire
pour cliquer c'est la pièce qui prend le
plus de temps à être bougé donc ça a
semblé intéressant de jouer une finale
de cavaliers avec un gros avantage à la
pendule
après c'est un peu des trucs de raccroc
c'est un peu des victoires on va dire à
l'expérience au finish mais pourquoi pas
la jouer vu que la stratégie d'alexandra
que c'est nukes et d'être mieux au temps
et de mettre la pression à la pendule
autant capitaliser jusqu'au bout je
trouve ça un peu dommage finale de
cavaliers égale gros avantage autant
pourquoi pas la jouer bon après
peut-être qu'elle gère son match et là
plus deux mais faut pas regretter les
occasions l'agglo qui a été un peu
peut-être tendre jeudi en début de match
et finalement elle a payé à la payer
puisqu'elle a perdu faux-pas faut pas
laisser passer l'occasion c'est pas des
peintres en face aux attentes spirale
est pas là pour
elle est pas là pour décorer un est là
pour gagner et c'est pas forcément c'est
pas forcément des demi point qu'on doit
laisser passer
après elle aurait pas forcément gagné
elle était même pas gagnante je crois
mais ça ça ça mérite et ça pour moi ça
mérite un petit risque
ça méritait ça méritait ou pequeno
risque d'un petit risque était était
pour moi tu entends table jeu juste pas
qualité à laquelle quel adjectif adverse
ou verbe employés mais voilà donc on a
deux nouveaux ces petites positions de
type de type slave ou les pions sans
trop se sont échangés donc là ça sort du
numéro indien a une nouvelle fois un
truc quasiment symétrique avec cette
petite pression blanche
attention kosteniuk moi je dis attention
parce que si la tendance qui a vu
qu'elle défend vraiment bien si elle
commence à réussir après c'est un peu
ces trucs là avec les blancs la
physionomie du match pour échanger c'est
pour ça qu'il faut vraiment qu'alexandra
passez pas à côté donc alexandra qui
joue actifs
c'est vrai que je me reconnais plus dans
le jeu d'alexandra qui ressemble le plus
à mon style
même si alexandra est plus forte que moi
dans tout l'est dans tous les
compartiments du jeu
on a des styles qui sont qui se
ressemble un petit peu donc je comprends
pourquoi là elle a ce genre de
répertoire cependant ses positions une
nouvelle fois un peu désagréable tu es
un peu sous pression avec les noirs et
les forces kényanes à réussir un seul
suspect dans un match où il n'y a aucun
m es et tu sais non mais c'est comme
quand enfin regarder le match
est ce qu'il ya des gens dans le chat
qui ont vu le match de bon va parler un
peu roland garros vite fait pour faire
un parallèle mais ce que vous avez le
match mahut checchinato gpat humaines de
7,0 tu lâches de cette vie passée qu'il
a tout commence un peu à lâcher les 7 et
tout finale
pourquoi tu rates 3 3 balles trois
balles de break ou quatre balles de
break dans le 5e set
o'keeffe a injecté plus fort c'est 19e
mondial tu comptes le 250e mondial tu
gagnes les deux premiers sets bon après
tu te relâches un peu dans le 3 et le
quatrième est dans le 5ème tu rates tes
balles de break et puis celle et puis
voilà enfin gers et ça va vite quoi
rater ces occasions dans tous les temps
dans toutes les compétitions quand on
atteint du haut niveau c'est toujours
dangereux
là on voit bien maintenant je te menace
qui a et b ça que je me lasserai
lecavalier je ne lâcherai cavalli c'est
cette eau kheddam v8 mais c'est quand
même tu te fais un peu pressé peut-être
qu'à ibb et 5 quand même d'ailleurs tu
vises un peu la casse c'est cette tu
ouvres ton fou n'est pas le c'est le
match qui peut vite tourner joueur tu
viens tu viens de rater un petit truc à
partie d'avant là tu te la fait coller
bungert au bout d'un moment comme dirait
fable 3 ou 4 1 c'est pas la même score
manqué food et st gall pour le moment
les noirs qui sont résistants et encore
de la marge dans cette position mais on
sait pas d'âme ses trois menaces
lecavalier lecavalier qui va quand même
arriver sur ces 7
bon il n'y arrive pas mais mais
peut-être qu'il peut y avoir du cac 2,4
qui marchent pas ok tout reprend des
cinq dames français 6 est-ce que c'est
faisable
ça peut peut-être gagné une pièce
puisque tout reprend des cinq en plus il
n'ya pas cavalier prend pas ce qu'il ya
d'étrange et sept matchs donc cavalier
tour prend des cinq à moins ce que je
sois fou à lier ce qui est possible mais
sinon il ya pions prend prises et sagan
une pièce on va le voir
e4 qui gagne peut-être une pièce aussi
je vais mettre leur dis ok tu reprends
des saints qui gagne une pièce mais eux
quatre ces la même en plus fort donc
l'appareil quand vous commentez c'est
plus dur à voir mais comme ya pas qu
elle provoque 4 d'un projet 7 et surtout
prend 1,4 et prend 1,4 voilà tu perds
une pièce
ouais je ne vais pas du suspense pour
rien c'est pas de la limonade c'est pas
du sirop là ce qu'on est en train de
regarder un cher c'est un vrai match de
haut niveau et tu peux pas rater des
occasions comme ça tu peux pas faire de
cadeau tu fais des cadeaux tu laisse
l'adversaire rentrer dans le jeu tu
mêles adverse
en confiance quand tu fais des cadeaux
et là il ya peut-être dû dams et 7 qui
avait pensé un et d'un pro russe est
peut-être tu peux pas tu peux pas faire
de cadeau à ses voix lasse pas possible
non mais c'est pas du sirop c'est pas
sucré
ce n'est pas une boisson sucrée est là
qu on est en train de regarder un
carrelet les joueuses elles en valent 1
je suis tu l'ès 1 mm tu veux tu dois pas
laisser le moindre millimètre jamais de
mm c'est monde à metz troyes qui doit
être très bien aussi
et elle fait des six soit j'aime bien
aussi elle passe bien son pion elle met
la pression là tu vas reprendre sa pièce
tu vas faire de la partie ce sera bien
fait si ça se paye cash les erreurs
comme ça ça se paye cash à ce niveau là
et encore une fois on parle pas que de
la position sur la partie d'avant et là
la dame qui va venir en b3 peut-être
dame b3 et sur damas huit peut-être
cavaliers à 3 pourtant fermé ta tour n
est bon travail que tu rates les
occasions ratées okaz un gilot rien
bordel mais je le droit quoi banon ne
t'a pas loin tmb 3 tu vas te faire
dominer torah 5 pouces et 3 dégage avec
la tour qu'avait laissé cette aussi
jouable un peut-être
vous ses droits à jouer vous c4 allez va
falloir le faire avec les blancs s'est
pas encore fini fini
qu'est ce que tu as un bon livre en
france s'est battue peut aller voir sur
sur mon site il ya des petits nés en
dessous et je vais faire un nouvel
article pour des livres là je suis en
train d'en acheter suis en train de
faire une commande de livres spéciale
pour pour les joueurs entre entre 800 et
1500 1600 histoire de pouvoir vous
conseillez donc je vais je vais lire un
peu tout ça et je pourrais vous en dira
un peu plus donc là le prime sur foot
champions prend c'est qu'on va réussir à
mettre le quart ayant décidé à pousser
en force
et si on prend pas le pion des 5 va
tomber et ça va faire 3 2 les erreurs se
payent cash
ray mais si elle n'avait pas fait nul à
la dernière tête elle aurait gagné c'est
la fin c'est toujours pareil les matches
c'est des rushes s'est tu laisse
l'adversaire sortir de l'eau ça change
tout ça change tout on va voir on va
voir comment elle va conclure avec les
blancs s'est pas encore tout à fait fait
alors lis c'est cool tu en feras une
vidéo ah non je n'en ferai pas une vidéo
j'en fais pas une vidéo mais ça me
permettra de d'étoffer un peu mes livres
pour les joueurs plus débutant même si
j'ai déjà du contenu mais ça me
permettra de donner des conseils de
lecture et en ce qui concerne chez cbl
n'ont jamais proposé de travailler avec
eux et de toute façon ça m'intéresse pas
donc
jenny une proposition ni l'intérêt de
bosser avec celle cbl en revanche c'est
fort possible enfin c'est plus que
possible que vous vous voyez bientôt
l'ouverture j'espère cours en 2019 2020
de d'une dune d'une plateforme de vente
vidéo j'ai envie de dire j'ai envie des
replis de stream ça c'est une autre
histoire donc fou des quatre elle va
s'en prendre aux pions b6
alors autant on en est où il ya quarante
secondes pour pour les
et blanc tu peu cher tu vas tu vas
trouver des liens en de soi c'était pas
sur ma chaîne ici ouais bitstream point
fr le pion le pion qui va tomber c'est
le seul petit truc ici c'est tout autour
des 5
mais à mon avis a l'embarras du choix
déjà à minima ya tour des cinq et on n'a
pas trop peur de tourner vite à cause de
17 mais aussi cavalier c7 crée une
menace tour des huit et maintenant vas
bouger l'autre cavaliers auxquels fait
cavalier ou six elle regagne un tempo
sur la tour alors comment est-ce qu'elle
va conclure sa cavaliers des 5 ou 17 17
et des 8 et ça va faire une pièce de
plus
bon c'est pas le truc le plus compliqué
du monde a gagné
il va falloir faire tour 17 et et bouger
le cavalier peut-être un petit coup de
hache 4 on prendre l'espace 3g 2 tours
17 cavaliers f7 cavaliers rentrée puis
ça va ça va y aller tout seul et on
menace cavaliers 600 plus séparé roigé
deux côtés ue qui s'accroche bien
cavalli c6 faut ramener le cavalier
enjeux cavaliers cet échec
bon ça c'est pas un problème a gagné
donc effet un regard froid f7 ici
broyage cette fois f7 avec l'idée c'est
sûr qu'il ya des cinq de fer droit
machin est brouillée ça pouvait faire
une double attaque pour le cavalier
blanc qui va arriver
gentiment en f5 le voile c'est du rhin à
ce niveau là ça fait froid je suis tjrs
pranger c'est toi
pat reprend g7 parce qu'on sait jamais
qui est des histoires de pâtes il y
avait un joli piège en fait tout reprend
g7 je pense qu'il y avait toujours eu
quatre échecs qui faisait pas 3.24 forcé
c'était pâte qu'elle a quand même réussi
à faire un un piège
ça lui suffit de rentrer sa part je vis
dans la ville natale le kosteniuk
décaler cette ville sammy harris du coup
c'est une info qui a un rapport avec le
match donc hausser new que ouais petit
petite alerte quand même hein comme je
vous ai dit elle a raté une occasion
après elle a joué là jusqu'au bout s'est
déjoué ce qui s'accroche mais souvent
les filles c'est un truc que j'ai
l'impression après c'est peut-être
peut-être moins qu'ils aient cette
impression mais j'ai l'impression que
les filles à haut niveau ça accroche
vraiment par rapport à leurs lots elle
s'accroche vraiment comme comme les
hommes à haut niveau en fait il ya
vraiment ça ça joue sajou vraiment
vraiment pas mal et ça s'accroche à fond
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment solide
elle laisse pas ls pas un millimètre à
leurs adversaires donc on est retourné
dans le groupe i dames décliner et on a
une structure de type carlsbad
donc cette position de type carlsbad les
blancs peuvent voir ou le plan de faire
la tacc de minorités ou le plan qu'elle
est en train de faire avec f 4g 4 f5 et
ça généralement je trouve que c'est très
bien
j'avais analysé une variante un peu
similaire à celle là pour les blancs et
après j'ai quatre à mon avis oui ou f5
direct même là c'est possible dans
l'autre il fallait faire un g4 dans ce
que j'avais analysé mais j'ai
l'impression que ça honnêtement c'est
juste formidable pour les blancs tu as
pris tellement d' espaces allaient droit
que tu tu marches sur l'adversaire quoi
tu marches sur l'adversaire à mon humble
avis en tout cas toutes les positions
similaires que j'avais à réaliser c'est
un gros avantage man tu me l'as déjà
même un truc comme si on prend qui on
prend fou prend qui on prendra me prend
et en fait à tellement de pièces sur les
droits là je crois que c'est juste c'est
juste une catastrophe pour les voir à
mon avis il est blanc joue correctement
c'est fini je peux vous illustrer avec
un truc genre prise à mettons reprise
prise reprise prises et ça et surtout à
fuiter adam g 5 échecs 3h huit cavaliers
à vii mat
bon c'est juste une variante pour vous
illustrer le truc hein pas même
cavaliers pros fc 3 prend et puis on
prend g6 qui mena à ce point là à mon
avis et c'est proche de termini alors
cavalli prend f7 est une option roi
prend qui on prend roi g8 puis on prend
rouages suite auquel et blanc peuvent
pas terminer le job donc elle se défend
contre ça bon là j'ai quatre malherbe
est fort sur cahier g3 noir tous rêvent
trois mois elle prend en premier manoir
une idée derrière la tête
ok elle peut prendre les prendre en fait
et rejouer ça ça une super tête mais
peut-être qu'à d'amd 600 corps qui sait
toujours faire gaffe quand vous
sacrifiez à ok mais sur age et ajustés
avec sa twingo sur fg il devait bien
avoir quelque chose à moi aussi j'avais
mis le mauvais coup devait bien avoir un
gain à tête j'ai quatre fois et je pense
j'ai quatre cavaliers m6 est fou pranger
ok c'était c'était à ces massacres en
quoi la gti premier set c'est à bon
droit la cfu pranger 6 au prochain le
fou car yvan h7 est ce genre de variante
où il ya les pions qui arrive facilement
à venir en f4 cavaliers 5
sas et je suis convaincu que les blancs
sont venus ici ça ressemble vraiment un
truc dans la cambridge prime que
j'analyse et et c'était cata pour les
noirs ça lui haddock ph qu'il met des
petits g4 dans le chatt bon mais
heureusement finalement qu'elle a laissé
passer l'occasion de ce qu'elle va
remonter à 4 2 c'est vrai que si elle
avait pas filer ses filets le demi point
tout à l'heure ça aurait encore fait
gonfler le score à la faut passer à
autre chose à te dire qu'ils essayent de
se défendre
franchement je ne vois pas dans quel
monde il peut il peut y avoir ici une
défense pour les noirs il ya la dame qui
a attaqué il ya le pion g6 en l'air je
vois pas trop je vois pas trop ce qui
peut fonctionner l'embarras du choix
mais juste vous pranger 6 1 et la
cavalerie si ce cahier qui revient aux
500 f 7 enfin bon cavalier ou 5 d'abord
aussi très bien enfin tout est bien là
là y'a pas y'a rien de mal
là on cherche un mauvais coup plutôt
pour pour les blancs cherche un coût qui
gagne pas parce que la foux projet si
sarah menacé x 7 sam n'acheter fou prend
1,8 mais elle s'accroche sur moi
j'aurais déjà abandonné depuis longtemps
bon là il ya à minima fou et 7
ces minima mais ces dames de plus
mais elle s'accroche c'est tout à son
honneur
moi j'aurais laissé filer la partie bien
plus tôt mais elle s'est accrochée à la
réussi à jouer quelques coups de plus
sans grand succès après à quel point est
ce qu elle
à quel point est-ce qu'elle a réfléchi
vraiment quand un joueur de position ou
pas ou est ce qu'elle joue vraiment
tranquille donc maintenant c'est la
petrov du côté de kosteniuk et on à la
variante qui est vraiment jouer en ce
moment au niveau avec cavaliers c3d
prends mes consignes qui a l'air d'être
assez heureuse que ses new skies est
tout sourire
sarko poser ses positions très théorique
ces cinq dons qu'elle envoie tout de
suite le jeu allait droit roye b 1b 5
aux cages ou la variante où on envoie
les pions pas mal en blitz vous prend
bessin qu'elle veut vite mètres la tour
en des 8es s'en prendre aux rois après
on peut quand même j'imagine prendre je
suis pas spécialiste mais on peut
prendre quand même tour b 8 et revenir
avec le foot puis jouer pour b3 plus
tard pourquoi aux finances ne s'est pas
direct à elle c'est parce que le titre
le changement de titre est pas passé les
mecs le changement de titre est pas
passé vous faites bien de me le dire je
vais pouvoir mettre le bon titre
des fois quand je mets le bon titre et
que je mets save ça marche pas donc j'ai
enlevé rediffusion c'est quand je change
de rediffusion jeu mais je change le
titre et ça pas du passé alors merci de
m'avoir prévenu je vais changer le truc
alors attendez j'ai ce bug de temps en
temps je sais pas d'où ça vient c'est
pas la première fois que ça me le fait
je pense que le changement de titre est
passé et en fait il n'est pas passé
je vais aller changer ça
je vais changer le truc
ouais non c'est vrai que parfois ça ça
change pas le titre vraiment désolé
c'est pas toujours c'est pas toujours
facile
c'est pas toujours facile ce genre de
petites erreurs quand tu t'occupes de
tout tout seul c'est pas c'est parce pas
évident de gérer tous ces trucs là
mettre les rediffusions les enlever le
machin ça prend du temps il suffit que
tu cliques que ça allait pas pris et
c'est la catastrophe à la ok j'espère
que cette mise à jour maintenant j'ai du
clic et ça n'a pas dû le prendre
bon ça doit être chose faite
passionné il ya un bug courant chez les
streamer utilisant twitch voyage du maïs
arrive pour les autres
anna la part des très positive j'ai pas
pu regarder la caméra du comme je
faisais ça mais je pense que ouais le
match forcément les pas en train de
prendre un bon tournant elle se prend
une grosse attaque sur le roi
l'attaquent des noirs va beaucoup plus
vite et ça m'a l'air d'être là la cata
faut vraiment qu'elle joue plus vite et
en fout des 4 pourquoi que je suis pas
d'être allé vite en besogne
c'est vrai que baisser fou prend pour le
moment ça tient damas 5
donc elle veut pas elle veut pas prendre
bien évidemment parce que quelque part
si c'est les blancs qui prennent à leur
prendra du fou et celles qui gagnent de
tempo et peut-être qu'elle peur à l'idée
de faire l'us tourbes et six tours à six
et de venir gagner le pion à 2 pardon à
3 et bien évidemment pas jouable mais du
coup tourbe et six tours à 6 peut être
une idée pour le moins ya le fou qui
colmate donc et jouer damas quatre tours
b 5 tours à 5 ça paraît un peu long avec
les blancs ans qu'on se demande c'est
comme envoyer la tacc qu'elle et noir
veulent peut-être aussi juste fèves 5 et
messac avec les blancs tu vois pas trop
le jeu où il va je parlais dur il y en a
pas là de très positif rey à nay paraît
pas et pas très très positive
qu'effectivement elle est un peu
négative je dirais même c'est la
négative à da pour anna qui manque un
peu de de joie de vivre il faut s'être
semble pousser vite dans les indiennes
ouais un peu de loin j'ai envie de dire
de loin
alors je me demande si on micro sature
pas un petit peu je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai l'impression que tu en d1
je vais un peu baissé la non mais je
sais pas ouais j'ai un peu baissé le
niveau du micro je pense qu'ils saturent
et un petit peu je suis pas sûr on va
voir je fais juste un petit est ok
désolé pour le petit bruit
il faut que je passe un peu un peu un
peu son volume
du coup j'ai quatre joué par les blancs
donc elle essaye d'envoyer à la beaucoup
réfléchi au parlement et noir ont pas de
menace mais peut-être gestion prend fou
prend fou b4 est une option c'est quand
la ronaldo venu kevin ya pas d'aveu nasa
d'arena des abonnés prévu louga pour le
moment vu qu'il ya pas vraiment de
possibilité de créer un un club spécial
abonnés ça peut être qu'il ya mais bon
on n'est pas on n est pas encore à ce
niveau là pendant ce n'est pas prévu bon
c'est déjà une option de fer prise prisé
fou b4 à mon avis ça permettra d'enlever
un défenseur de la casse b2 bon
commencer par axis ça ça mange pas de
pain qu'ils allaient h3 et fou pranger 4
ok en fait elle veut elle voulait sur
pions prend jouer cavalier e 4 puis on
prend ces 3 et du coup elle aurait elle
n'aurait pas été re prenable parce que
la casse et trois étaient plus concis
plus plus de mieux contrôler par les
noirs mais ce que j'aime pas trop avec
ce fou g4 c'est qu'elle laisse tour g1
du coup et finalement les blancs sont
contents parce qu'avec les blancs on
savait pas comment attaquer et kosteniuk
y vient de nous ouvrir maintenant la
dame prend 1,6 éventuellement
pas le seul coup mais on peut faire un
truc comme d'un projet si ce fou j'ai
six tours pranger 6 on en voit la
qualité agents renvoyer la qualité tu
vois perso je suis allé à envoyer sa et
j'aurais joué cette position a mais
doivent avoir peur de pions france et 3
ici voilà sûrement bien fait de pas le
faire pour ça qu'elle est revenue courir
en d2 parce que c'est vrai qu' on prend
ces trois étaient pénibles donc elle
recouvre la casse ces trois espions
français 3 puis on prend ces trois fous
b4 qui était l'idée qu'on avait depuis
tout à l'heure et ça va quand même pour
les noirs un millavois reprise tout
reprend donc on menace tour prend b2 et
chaque attention on a une petite
découverte ici les blancs qui prennent
ici c'est la tour prend b2 fin de
l'histoire
bon il fallait peut-être faire roi c1
mais c'était complètement foutue glonass
tourbe et huit dames ces trois matches b
you un petit frisson peut-être d'un
prend ici c'est vrai mais le truc avec
fougue et 4 c'était vraiment très fort
est ce que tu es sûr que l'on met les
pieds dans le bon sens
on n'est jamais sûr de rien mais je
crois oui on n'est jamais sûr de rien
mais il aurait du mal être dans l'autre
sens en fait quoique qui s'est attiré
dans le mauvais sens vous étiez en
mauvais sens mais à 2,60 j'ai bientôt
changer mon cet appel sont épars mauvais
donc
donc ce n'est pas un problème
voilà le capteur il doit être plus bas
et il faudrait il faudrait peut-être
qu'il soit retourné dans l'autre côté
bon je sais pas peu importe si tu peux
m'envoyer une photo mais je voudrais
acheter un bras extensible de toute
façon quand j'aurai mon nouveau set up
ce sera plus pratique on se sent
ingé-son voilà de nouveau cette petite
position à la sortie d'une petrov donc
on est parti dans des dans un foot
petrov causé new qui jouent cette vente
avec dam des trois que qui ressemble
comme je disais une variante des changes
de 2 la française en un poil mieux mais
pour ition égal il faut il faut
absolument que que chess queen que que
atone ce qui rejoue plus vite parce que
sinon tu es queen va lui marcher dessus
et là on a de nouveau une position
complètement égalisant j'ai envie de
dire peur peut-être des cinq coûter 6,6
remettre le cavalier vers f4 je vois je
vois pas vraiment pourquoi les noirs
aurait le moindre problème
tel un jeu peut-être dam des six tours 8
bref tous ces positions mieux que moi
donc on lui fait confiance mais
kosteniuk équivoque est bon c'est quand
même à à noter que c'est la première
partie dans laquelle il n'ya pas il n'y
a pas de vraie pression à la pendule
donc ça c'est une quand même une une
assez bonne nouvelle pour pour anna
c'est la première fois qu'elle se fait
pas quelques elle se fait pas dominer
autant et ça c'est plutôt positif pour
elle parce qu'avant c'était c'était la
deuxième 2
domina dalo temps là j'imagine que des
cinq du coup devient une option mais
peut-être qu'à rallier le 5 mai aura pas
cavalier e 4 ok faut regarder des cinq
cavaliers eu cinq cavaliers prend qui on
prend cavaliers 4 qu'elle n'est pas
rentrer là dedans elle vient tenir la
case de 4 et du coup cavaliers aux 5 et
cavaliers f5 qui rôde un peu près ce que
cette dame en b si c'est si bien placé
on ne sait pas on va voir peut-être
faire tout re 1 8
l'échangé des pièces et tenir permettra
d'amender 8 et attendre ce que les
blancs peuvent vraiment créer des
menaces at handicap j'ai quand j'ai
surtout si dans ma chambre et que des
cours vidéos ouais parce qu'en fait on
va on va on va tout refaire albator est
ce que démentent est parti passer de
qualification compétition n'ont
malheureusement démente et ne
représentera pas nos couleurs j'ai envie
de dire mais on commentera le match ce
sera jeudi
jeudi 30 donc il sera fériée en plus
je dit anton commentera avec femmes le
match match qui sera intéressant ce sera
ce bac contre arica donc se conclure à
une joueuse française
il y aura une joueuse française qui qui
représentera les couleurs tricolores
pour notre plus grand bonheur
parti qui est toujours dominé autant par
les blancs et là un petit temps d'arrêt
pour pour anaky a du mal à trouver son
organisation défensive
elle fait des bonnes parties mais elle
prend trop de temps elle prend trop de
temps cas d'essayer de faire ces cinq ce
qui est une autre possibilité
quand tu sens que ça va pas trop pour
jouer le pion isolé qui peut comme comme
il va y avoir beaucoup des changes être
viable est ce qui a influencé dans le
speech et juniors malheureusement non
j'aurais souhaité que bill elle
participe quand on avait quand il y
avait eu un sondage pour savoir quels
joueurs voulez-vous que qui participent
au speech as junior j'avais proposé
entre guillemets la candidature de bilal
bilal benhacen mai mais ça pas été
retenu malheureusement j'ai envie de
dire alors est ce que c'est parce que
son lots sur une chaise comme est un peu
faible mais il est bon en blitz il
aurait pu il aurait pu défendre ses
couleurs
après on a un joueur français bien non
bien évidemment dans le speech s hommes
puisque on abat l'un des favoris de la
compétition maxime vachier lagrave qui
se fait toujours éliminé par notre ami
icaro peut-être cette année ce sera
finalement la bonne écart ou qui lui ne
perd que contre magnus donc comme ça il
ya une une certaine progression dans la
méchanceté alors qu'anna est parti à la
quitter sa chaise et elle est revenue
bon
maintenant elle va devoir défendre le
pion isolé un qui est une faiblesse
l'officier qui est au niveau du langage
corporel kosteniuk a l'air beaucoup plus
à l'aise que la même que l'american way
mais après les plus fortes
quand tu es plus fort et tu sais que tu
es plus fort c'est sûr plus facile tu
manos corte plus forte a pas le temps de
pata pas le temps de te sentir mal en
fait
kabila était peut-être trop même après
les règles comme si tu as comme qui les
écrit il aurait pu il aurait pu faire
une exception
enfin ils auraient pu mettre qui voulait
en fait ils n'ont pas retenu peu importe
après c'est vrai que tous les joueurs
qui sont soit ils sont vraiment très
jeune genre dragan honda ou niall sarine
les joueurs les moins forts sont
vraiment très jeunes ils ont genre 14 15
ans et après dans les joueurs qui ont
qui ont la vingtaine qui ont la
vingtaine tout juste ils ont pris des
cadors ils ont pris ou et ils ont pris à
phil rogers il est jeune aussi mais ils
ont ils ont pris des très bons donc ça
se comprend
kameneff 4 ok bon pour le moment ça
semble aller pour les noirs malgré le
plus isolé ya pas mal d'activités j'ai
l'impression que ça se tient
ça s'est un peu isolé c'est dur de taper
dessus pour taper un pur isolé faut
quand même qu'ils aient des pièces
lourdes hockey du couac change et elle
va jouer pour ce petit pion faible à
être continue à vue pour l'activité
kosteniuk elle continue à jouer à fond
pour l'activité
c'est vraiment une joueuse active elle
joue vraiment bien quand elle s'active
droit qui part en a je pète fait retour
à 2 ici elle veut préparer peut-être un
coup comme g3 mehal pions b2 vrai nom
j'ai trois tours deux ça al'air faisable
elle colle matt mémoire elle a plu
davantage fait cavalier e 4 ici un jour
pour menaces et qu'elle prend ses trois
entoure ces deux couvre d'attenté un
truc actifs c4 et c5 mais bon gars qui
ont des seins qui ferait ça en l'air
après un cavalier e set aussi qui
attaquera la mais surtour ces deux je
vois pas où est le problème pour les
blancs c'est ce qu'elle joue d'ailleurs
h5 bon ça c'est genre de coups que tu
joues qu'on t'a pas quand tu sais pas
exactement de quoi jouer tu pousses
champions h
et en plus ça prépare peut-être un peu
g6 kf3 le retourne avec le cavalier g6 a
à faire cavalier seul j'imagine mon y
aura toujours des quatre cavaliers trois
des quatre ça revient pas aux mêmes du
tout puisque cavaliers celle du cavalier
aurait été mal placée en recettes à ce
moment là donc a valu à trois mieux
jouer mais ça retombe dans ce que plus
ou moins ce que je pensais
ok ça c'est bien joué parce qu'elle a
pour prendre le pion des 4 elle a réussi
à gagner un pion mais difficile de jouer
avec des seconds à la pendule
mais maintenant elle va envoyer son but
sur moi alors c'est pas encore fait
parce que sur b4 moment il ya ka et des
trois échecs tout reprendre et de et
cavaliers prend b4g enfin faire 3-3 mais
c'est vrai que l'ailé noire s'approche
maintenant du pion h5
est-ce qu'elle va t'on tb4 échanger et
envoyer le pion b les blancs qui vont
prendre h mes béquilles et dangereux
donc elles gardées tour de cou sur
l'échiquier maintenant le cavalier va
partir et elle va faire baisser un grain
en les blancs sont très bien le pion b
est très difficile à arrêter b5 b6
bessette les noirs qui vont être short
aller nigel bale va réussir à mettre un
cavalier en b 8 dont 4 cavaliers e18
cavaliers f6 qui a aidé cet été une
option mais bon elle va faire tour c'est
un tour c'est 8 oui s'est excusé moi
très bien joué et tour c8 qui va menacer
le cavalier oui c'était c'était le bon
plan ça fait plus ce 4rm maintenant l
heure elle est tout en contrôle
elle joue plus vite un elle joue pas
mieux elle joue plus vite ce qui veut
dire quelque part qu'elle joue mieux
parce que si l'autre avait le jouer au
même niveau il pourrait jouer aussi vite
mais elle fait la différence dans les
ait note
l'ordi et même contre ayem se trouve si
ça change pas mal non ben ouais on
parlait aussi de ça avec fab tout à
l'heure au téléphone je lui disais en
fait là j'ai pas mal joué ces deux trois
derniers passés de cette dernière
semaine sur tu as comme j'ai pas mal
joué de mon côté un peu hors des arénas
et tous genres en jouant vraiment
sérieux contre contrainte à joueur
différent parce que les arénas non mais
c'est cool mais genre en fait quand tu
joues contre des mecs de ton niveau que
tu joues pas mal de parties
quelque part c'est un intérêt qui est
différent c'est un autre type de jeu
mais voilà ça change un peu comme vous
savez ça marche un peu par terre par
périodes dans les stream fait beaucoup
de de quelque chose après vous faites un
peu autre chose mais met donc là j'avais
envie en tout jouer même offs crime tout
ça et je remarque qu'il ya une
différence énorme entre les joueurs à
[Musique]
2005 2005 50 genre jusqu'à 2005 2005 50
je tiens plus ou moins suivant les
joueurs suivants les répertoires et tout
ça est en fait dès que les mecs sont
classés allez on va dire 2005 50 c'est
vraiment la limite où je peux encore
tenir dès que les joueurs soient 25 81
26 j'ai l'impression que la différence
de niveau est juste énorme et genre là
les 40 50 points de différence genre
2005 je suis juste certains chiens
certains d'autres non mais on va dire je
suis juste juste 25 50 je suis déjà mal
mais on va dire il ya encore un peu
match ça joue encore bon je suis dominé
message ou et 25 81 26 en fait si c'est
un bon buteur à 25,86 c'est juste un
massacre j'arrive juste pas donc c'est
vrai qu'en réalité cette différence de
niveau entre quelqu'un qui est 24 50 et
25 50 et une grosse différence il ya
plus de différence contre 1,14 sans
aucun sens
donc est en partie l'onctueuse serait
2005 non non non pas du tout en partie
longue de toute façon j'ai joué onze
partis depuis deux ans donc c'est pas
énorme mais ça donne une petite idée je
crois que j'ai une perf à 23,50 donc je
vais à peu près jouer à ça après j'ai
des problèmes de pratique j'ai pas de
répertoire et tout ça donc j'ai pas mal
de choses qui me handicape mais du coup
ça veut dire qu'avec ces petits
handicaps c'est à peu près mon niveau 23
30 23 50
donc peut-être que super bien préparés
machin et tout j'arrive à 24 24 50 vent
dans le dos mais mais jamais plus et
c'est ça on travaillons beaucoup et on
est en remettant mon répertoire à jour
et et on travaille on les échecs on va
dire trois quatre heures par jour
pendant six mois tous les jours pas cinq
jours par semaine telles j'arrive à 24
24 50 ans dans le dos mais pas plus
jamais de la vie
et aujourd'hui 23 23 50 c'est à peu près
mon niveau mais j'ai pas de répertoire
donc c'est pas si mal
genève 23 50 ma perf est peut-être un
peu vent dans le dos comme dirait
mathieu c'était plutôt 2003 venu en fait
mon lots quelque part près mon niveau
aujourd'hui avec le répertoire de quand
j'ai arrêté ouais je sais ça doit être
ça 23 124 peut-être 24 sur 24 24 quelque
chose mais donc forcément entre 23 50 24
même si je suis bon beat seraient tous
contre un bon buteur à 25 50 26 l'écart
est énorme
donc cette position il ya de nouveau un
pion isolé pour les noirs un petit peu
d'activité c'est quoi mon répertoire
pour avec les blancs c'est juste une
absence de répertoire donc soit 2,4 soit
des cas plutôt des quatre essais des
systèmes de londres où des trucs avec
eux trois rapide et avec les noirs
scandinaves mais slave
mais le truc c'est que au lieu de
connaître la théorie comme avant
jusqu'au 16e 17e coup je connais
jusqu'au septième ou huitième donc ça
fait quand même une différence assez
grande
ok donc à piau isolant dessin à
contre-pied en isolant c3 mais ils sont
plus facile d'attaquer celui en d5
quoique à vue de nez je préférais les
blancs mais en fait le fou est arrivé en
c4 mais maintenant je pense plus que les
blancs et un avantage quelconque 1 la
dame qui peut vite venir verra si cela
tour ans et 8 la dame en a trois on va
mettre la pression sur ces deux mecs là
ça va très bien pour les noirs n'ont
remarqué une position très correcte et
une nouvelle fois une meilleure pendule
donc château réunion ces deux pour
anticiper un petit coup de hache si ça
évitera les fous g5 fouet trois fous des
quatre qui arrive c'est peut-être pas
bête comme ça elle peut reprendre 2 cl
se refait la structure réalisable le
pion des cinq mais il sera bien défendus
par le fou mais peut-être un peu joué ou
trois mois je sais pas la 9-5
food & gas donc cette idée de reprendre
probablement de ces c'est pour ça que
les noirs touche à rien peut-être un
poil plus agréable à jouer pour les
noirs en plus avantage de pendule allait
de 4 ça envoie enfin puis on prend 1,4
fou prend 1,4 et peut-être qu'on a du
mal à regarder à rester au contact du
fou mais d'un autre côté il n'y a pas de
fou prend 1,6 pour le moment puisque la
tour et là le fouet cloud et donc on
peut jouer juste un coup comme dame h5
peut-être la dame sera pas mal placée
elle visera beaucoup de cases et sur
quoi les blancs vont tenter de se dé
cloud est bon avait que 4 je sais pas
elle a voulu ouvrir le jeu met la
pression mais finalement ouais quoi que
vous prend des captures on prend des 4
ce sera un pion pas s'est isolée pour y
avoir des échanges massif et on pourrait
tenir compte le pion
dames eu trois donc vous prend des
quatre en premier puis on prend et
maintenant peut être un truc comme fou
des cinq blocs et le pion à tour huit
avants bien joué elle profite du cloud
âge ça c'est bon coup tours 8 parce que
dame f4 des clous pas la tour serait pas
protégé faut peut-être repartir en d2 ou
en c1 anciens sacrés 1 contre cloud âge
d'ailleurs bbc un coca est ce qu'elle va
faire c'est qu'elle veut elle veut
accrocher le fou ici food étroit
possible parce que surtout reprendre à
me prendre des vies la dame mais ça
reste flou et donc foot est roi est
possible est ce que c'est bon crise
prises et d'amd 5 sûrement c'est ce que
j'étais en train de regarder dame c3 et
ça doit juste être égal parce que le
pion c4 avant sera jamais ok elle joue
pour la gagne dames france et katia
tourer c'est très bien jouer c'est très
bien joué fair tour f1 est maintenant
tour ces deux
que c'est nous qui jouent vraiment bien
quand elle quand elle à l'activité elle
a trouvé ça très vite dames 3 et
peut-être tout reprend à deux n'étant
pas de la tour va pouvoir partir
peut-être tour c'est un peut-être tour
c1 dames détroit yade a mis huit échecs
dames price est je crois encore que
des toiles peut-être pas idiot dame hui
3h cette dame f7 et peut-être qu'ils ont
c'est 3 et la dame en d3 colmater bien
tout ce qu'elle fait tour ces deux mais
en fait on peut pas faire tout reprend
prise d'armes huit dames premier set
parce que les noirs vont contrôler cette
diagonale le rasseoir atteint ce rang h7
y aura aucun échec et le pion c'est va à
dame
ok mais ça c'est ridicule ça c'est un
suicide d'amd 3 c3 ces deux c'est fini
bon c'est trois haies dames détroit
après j'ai pas trop compris le projet en
fait qu'elle a peut-être faire dame ces
quatre équidés d'amd 2e dessin qui est
récupéré cette diagonale c'est pour ça
que j'aurais commencé par dame détroit
pour éviter sa dame d enquête fut peut
être le rend h2o en g2 ces deux des cinq
dames des 5
et là il ya dam des trois noms mais la
dame détroit donc été envoyé le pion des
elle va envoyer le pion à mais ça ça va
gagner c'est sûr
à 5 des cinq à quatre des six à 3,17 à
deux des huit bouffe des huit bouffe ces
deux sur échec donc les rouages de force
et maintenant tête à cinq pions des
dessins kedar f5 bien joué ok faut faire
rager 2 milliard à 4 ou d'un me 3 hockey
mesdames e3 dame prend des 5 il n'y a
pas d'échec fois non mais ça sentait que
c'était du suicide d'aller d'aller
d'aller prendre en c2 et faire damer
huit dames f7 après avait pas trop
d'autres options mais ça ça perdait
direct ça c'était foutu direct et
c'était la dernière partie de la cadence
et ça fait 7 2 grosse grosse grosse
domination de d'alexandra qui domine
vraiment le match de la tête et des
épaules 7,2 au final c'est un peu
dommage de dire ça pour
pour anna d'attendrir mais méritée elle
joue plus vite elle joue mieux les mecs
ont fait une petite pause on se fait un
petit coup de pub et on est de retour
dans cinq minutes
[Musique]
les mecs on est de retour à la sortie de
la pub
salut allocs chess salut tout le monde
nacarat qui est très heureux ménage été
moins heureux quand il a joué contre
gritche aucun il faisait moins le malin
contre gries tchouk qui a vu la vidéo
d'art que j'ai posté ce matin dans le
dans le chatt salua sert une fin qui a
vu la vidéo du matin l'as riespach joue
quand ce sera jeudi fou 31 chaque manie
de la vue tammy 1 pouces bleus oui non
on ne sait pas alors c'est pas encore
reparti cris talent qui l'a vu aussi
salut crypte al-saffar moment qu'on t'a
pas vu crypte talent qu'est ce que tu
deviens non c'est vraiment une belle
partie un peu dur à expliquer mais joli
10 mois qui viennent ce que tu as le
livre de salaire game challenger et si
oui qu'ils en pensent quoi non gelée pas
mais je sais que c'est un bon livre
n'est juste ça me saoule et de lâcheté à
cet art est 6 heures c'est quoi un crème
des lois commenté wailly contre prague
amanda
un match intéressant à mon avis qui sera
vraiment à sens unique malheureusement
mais on essaiera de garder le suspense
un maximum et espérer que prague avait
mandat soit surprenant mais comme je
disais quand moi quand je les jouais
quand fable à jouer en rapide on n'a pas
du tout été impressionné par prague
amanda et oui c'est juste un des 20
meilleurs joueurs du monde et prague
allemande a en 3 + 2 je me demande s'il
est vraiment plus fort que moi mon
reader est un peu mais ce n'est pas pas
beaucoup donc j'imagine un gros massacre
on verra oui on veut que tu regardes on
ne se fait juste un moment qu'on t'a pas
qu'on t'a pas vu quoi donc là vous avez
la date 1 le 30 mai donc demain il y
aura gunino contre crush on va quand
même une joueuse de notre équipe de pros
chess league
valentina et contre irina crunch et le
30 donc le match qui nous intéresse le
plus finalement puisque ce sera le match
de la joueuse française et s'il ya
quelque chose de particulier pour
devenir streamer dans les lieux renens
tu peux devenir streamer il suffit juste
d'avoir une caméra un micro et de parler
et tu te sens streamer allez c'est
reparti le 3 + 1 donc on est parti pour
une heure de 3 + 1 et changements de
changement de d'ouverture alors ça c'est
un truc que j'ai du mal à comprendre
on était sûrs du e 4 ou alors elle avait
quand même commencer par elle avait
quand même jouer des quatre avec à noter
quand même en train dé à tien dans des
catalanes et on partait à la vidéo de ce
matin donc b5 ce serait le coût de 2 à 4
ce matin et a6 et l'autre variante pour
jouer b5 sur quoi à quatre élèves
normalement food et cette dame de france
et quatre pouces et 6 je crois en tout
cas en france et quatre pouces et 6
voilà c'est ça c'est la théorie car ils
essaient 3 donc les noirs qui ont réussi
à sortir leur fouet qui contrôle bien le
centre de la russie le seul à être
frustrés par l'échiquier bleus non moi
aussi je suis frustré parce que tu vois
j'ai fait un fonds vert qui va avec
l'échiquier vert et là du coup je me
retrouve avec un échiquier bleus pas de
chance dépi colombo dans le tchat
donc avalise c3 je me rappelle plus de
la théorie ici c'est pas mon répertoire
je connais jusque là mais pas plus loin
mais ça continue ça continue ça continue
b5 seller dam des trois dames des 3b 4
elle s'en prend aux cavaliers salua le
jaune dans le chat qui est bien fou aux
quatre daims de d1 on recule donc les
blancs qui ont toujours l'avantagé
d'options centraux qui ont faire
cavalier des deux qui vont chasser le
fou mais et noir qui font ces cinq là je
pense que les noirs ont complètement
égaliser mais c'est dommage que dans la
théorie le fou 17 pouces et 6 to sah
truc que tu peux jouer quasi tempo elle
prend 10 secondes pour le faire 10 15
secondes alors qu'elle doit connaître
pour se remémorer alors c'est pas énorme
énorme les mecs mais cinq dix quinze
secondes vu qu'elle est plus lente ça
peut faire la différence
alors qui a aidé deux poupées 7
évidemment garde la paire de fouka
vallée b 3 s'en prend aux pions c5 et
surprise elle reprendra peut-être du
cavalier et elle réussira à faire
rapidement fusé simple dames des trois
tours c'est un peu reprendre de la dame
aussi d'ailleurs mais je pense que c'est
la dame noire qui un peu plus de
problème à trouver des cases elle prend
de la dame est mais c'est aussi
complètement jouable il va jouer cette
finale
et finalement elle va réussir à rentrer
à s'activer en premier non allez allez
allez allez un peu mieux encore un
médecin malade et blanc mais là elle un
petit c'est plus facile à jouer c'est un
peu plus facile à jouer cavalier f prend
et du couffo prend roi prend et sur qui
a aidé cette crise et six cavaliers à 5
fu et trois tours d un ça ça vient bien
quoi donc dur de développer le cavalier
tour ses huit en premier pour éviter les
cavaliers sait si c'est peut-être à le
jouer calais 17 maintenant au prochain
cavaliers à 5
elle empêche t elle veut jouer vraiment
cavaliers c6 peut-être fou c
cinq ans du fou 3 s est pas évident
comme position à jouer food et 8 c'est
bien joué
elle veut pas laisser les cavaliers
rentrée alors est-ce que les pcet ici
une option peut-être
les revenus et du coup cavaliers c6 elle
joue vraiment pas mal ses positions
zaton spire satour quand des quatre le
pion est attaqué à 5 maintenant le pion
à 5 et un peu mal placé puisque le
cavalier b3 l'attaquent naturellement
peut-être faire qui est des cinq
cavaliers vrai nom je sais pas c'est
toujours un peu chiant ses positions que
tu as dit c'était une catalane ouest et
une catalane c'est j'ai toujours et je
trouve toujours ses positions un peu
désagréable à jouer pour les noirs y a
rien à faire auquel assure-t-on d66 afu
prend avec 2 le chip aux amis à roy
prend quelques 4 prises prise tour ces
deux noms ça marche pas désolé je
pensais que ça a marché mais ça marche
pas je pensais qu'on récupère et un
deuxième tueur en b2 où on a eu 2 mais
en fait non qu'elle va échanger et
cavaliers des 5 alors est ce que le
petit - du pion à cinq attaques et c'est
grave je crois pas au calme et le
cavalier en b si ça joue vraiment bien
ses positions avec les noirs pour ceux
qui jouent la catalane c'est vraiment ou
qui veulent jouer contre la catalane
c'est vraiment un match intéressant et
là elle veut cavaliers c4 et y'aura pas
tour ces deux à cause de cavaliers aux
cinq échecs à la vraiment vraiment bien
joué avec les noirs
c'est dommage qu'elle soit un peu lente
1 auquel idées sur ko keckeis et quatre
tours ces deux possibles le cavalier
protège joue bien aussi kosteniuk 1
je viens qu'elle repart sur pied et b6
et peut-être tour d2 le retour tour des
notes à tour ses cadres du coup c'est
mettre la pression comme ça
éventuellement doublé tour des de sa
transposerait dans la position faut pas
qu'elle prenne trop de temps elle fait
tour ses six arrêts profite de ce temps
là quand même
pour mettre son cavalier en c6 détroit
ok la cavale est ici est jouable est
l'hôte a juste fait reculer ces quatre
cavaliers prend et tour v8 la tourbe et
8 plus tôt voilà fait cavalier prends
ton vérité peut-être un coup après
attention à les noirs ont des problèmes
de maths du couloir qui lui non plus
quel hacker prend 1,5 à refaire tours à
huit et tout reprendre à quatre mais
trois cas tu as eu tour b1 avec tours b
8 maths qui arrivait touran os à
défendre et peut-être pas donc elle a
bien fait de jouer comme ça mais la tour
blanche qui va arriver en 17 et
cavaliers ou cinq qui va menacer quai
des quatre maintenant f5 rsa presse un
peu ok on va voir cette province car
mouche qui eux quatre pays ces cinq elle
va revenir
ça c'était écrit à le menacer une
fourchette
carrillo cinq échecs 3g 3l seulement
diagonale par rapport aux cavale f4 f5
ou e4 f4 f5 ça va arriver à le remettre
l'option ici attention il y avait
cavaliers des six qui menaçaient au ls
mac à loches incroyable quelle erreur ça
c'est une grosse erreur
bon alors c'est pas si simple à gagner
pour les noirs il faut garder la tour
bien loin pour gagner un peu de temps
pour le moment
auquel elle va réussir à ok c'est bon
bref 4 comprend et ours et 5h hockey
fait ces intermédiaires mais tout
reprend 1,4 prache 4 et on peut même pas
faire roi reprend m6 à cause de tournage
six échecs
ouais un coin kosteniuk y aller c'est la
qualité en un incroyable
elle a voulu jouer trop vite alors
qu'elle était en train de presser elle
aurait juste bouger la tourelle faisait
f5 cavale ie6 et je pense que vu la
pendule elle avait des chances de la
gagner encore que les noirs auraient
peut-être pu faire du surplace bon je
pense que ça va pas lui coûter bien cher
elle a encore quatre points d'avance
mais bon ça veut dire qu'on bullet hell
et peut-être pas tant au dessus que ça
donc ph lisalla fait marrer ouais ça m'a
fait marrer mais bon ça c'est pas très
drôle non plus qu'on va leur palmarès et
a donné une kalach en un coup quand même
fin j'ai pas fasse pas très drôle quoi
ce pas tabou ce pas tabou elle a donné
une cale au chan naing dams et 7
je crois une nouvelle position quasi
symétriques une nouvelle fois des petits
problèmes pour les noirs de
développement les plus haut possible y
avait six fours bessette bien évidemment
c'est une première option de jeu une
deuxième option seydoux avait que 5 fu
au cices
elle a attendu le cadre pour faire
cavalier h5 et elle va jouer pour la
case f4 attention aussi à cavaler le g3
qui peu rodé c'est empêcher
il vient des croûtons manière décrite
comme cette cavalière quatre
intermédiaires
dames 1
pourquoi pas d'âme des deux ça va
échapper à peut-être tour des huit la
gêner les blancs qui sont un peu mieux
sur cinq le cavalier arrivant des 5
peut être un peu pénible cavaler g6
c'est bien joué et il ya toujours ce
problème de finir le développement le
fou c'est 8 qui restent enfermés et
c'est pas simple simple
c'est pas simple simple les blanc qui
doit bien réfléchir ici pour conserver
la pression qu'ils mettent sur
l'adversaire des trois dames h5 que
c'est nous qui a besoin de jouer actifs
qu est-ce que c'est pas une joueuse qui
peut vraiment rester longtemps en
défense est là elle a besoin de
s'activer
donc c'est plutôt des positions qui sont
intéressants pour pourra tenir parce que
celle peut mettre un léger danger mais
là peut-être le temps de faire fou 17
maintenant parce qu'à 4 c'était bien
joué
f4 marche pas donc à faire faire j'ai 3
mais a le temps de faire pousser 6
kosteniuk qui va réussir à égaliser
c'est bien joué de la part de la joueuse
russe qui est pas loin d'égaliser l'a
peut-être s'inquiète un coût pour les
blancs pour jouer carey lieu 4k réalité
si ce n'est pas en carélie noir qui va
revenir vers recettes des cinq noms
miles kane yquem un plus pour les blancs
encore un petit plus cavalier 4 ça va
arriver c'est sûr et peut-être tout
reprend d un tour prend d un tour
cavaliers de dessins qui est tour si
d'ailleurs et oursaire je pense faire
cavalier ou 4 vraiment venir sur cette
case des six noms il ya ce petit plus
c'est encore un petit plus pour les
blancs ok cahier des cistes pas possible
via cavalia 3 donc elle empêche le roi
f3 bien placé ce qui fait une diagonale
par rapport aux cabale donc ça c'est
toujours intéressant à lecavalier du
coup est loin du roi bessin qu'elle veut
ouvrir une colonne faut peut-être jouer
à 5 1 se jouer la gagne
ce que tu veux faire cavalier des six tu
fermes là que tu gagnes la colonne c'est
avec cavaliers des six c'est fait tu
veux fermer la colonne des avec
lecavalier et gagner la colonne s'est du
coup tu fermes une colonne et la colonne
ou vertu là et le pion à six qui est
fixé là je pense kosteniuk qui souffrent
tour ces six sociétés une menace
maintenant ce pion est faible je pense
tour ces six femmes est intéressant et
cavaliers c5
il peut pas y avoir de découverte avec
le cavalier parce qu'il ya diagonale
pour moi tour c615 ou qui est une très
bonne tête
ok prendre prise prisé tour c6 hockey et
cavaliers c5
et il trouve que ça marchait pas kf5 il
faut autour c'est un as à dire fallait
jouer le truc le truc de base qu'à
valider si c'est fermé jeu mais j'ai pas
trop aimé la prison f6 elle aurait pas
pris en effet s'ils savaient pas tour
des six ans fait de base peut-être c'est
ça en fait qu'il a mis dans le mal
pourquoi les pros elle s'est séparée du
pion aux cinq qui paraissait si faure
devait y avoir une raison qui m'a
échappé
je vais je vais revenir sur ce moment là
parce que ça m'intéresse personnellement
des fois je commence je suis un peu le
truc qui m'intéresse aussi tu vois un
vrai tour ses six tours c'est cisco
numéro de l'ordi ffe roi a eu cet écart
est lié ces 5
il te dit même j'ai ktk et ses 5 avec
quoi comme défense allait tout réfuté
chaque et cavaliers c3 tous réfutent
échec à y avait pas de place pour le roi
c'était ça le piège j'ai passé à la vue
ou pas parce que c'était bien sûr
c'était vicieux comme menace est donc il
fallait commencer fallait mettre un g4
intermédiaire pour se donner des espaces
pour le roi et jouer cette idée là quand
même
et maintenant le problème c'est que les
noirs se sont bien recroqueviller et
veulent tourbe et cinq tours prend à 5
donc il faut aller pour cavalières et
cavaliers prend à chis je pense
peut-être dommage a reperdu les deux
coups droits que kiev 7 qui est prend
1,6 c'était quand même un pion et le
pion h en plus c'est un pion qui filait
je sais pas quel point elle a eu raison
de le laisser le pion à 6,20 en l'air ok
là faut tenter un faut prendre les faire
cavalier 7 à plus de temps mais ont un
langage 5
elle va prendre là nul mais peut-être à
la rater j'arrive parvenir à rebondir
peut-être bien plus tôt là peut-être un
moment donné et qui a valu à vii
cavaliers h6 qui sait après tours b 5
surtout bon je sais pas je suis pas sûr
pour la finale qui a continué finalement
auquel à jouer la gagne
les pions qui s'échangent hockey à tous
qui s'échangent et c'est nul ça saigne
là malgré le plus en plus car les b2
roy et 15.4 plus simple ça permet de
faire nul direct elle n'était pas si
loin une nouvelle fois avec les blancs 1
that inscrire qui manque un peu de peps
qui manque un peu de peps en fin de
partie allait un peu un peu juste un peu
des fouets f4 savez une partie en propre
châssis que je pense ou mathieu cornette
avait dit que dd c'était s'était planté
ça manque un peu de peps
ça manque un peu de un peu de vitesse
finalement il ya que quatre points
d'écart honnêtement dans le contenu
allait pas si loin ça t'inspire
c'est ce qu'a dit si ce pardon c'est
juste ça ressemble à un autre truc j'ai
craqué je regardais je regardais autre
chose j'ai craqué ça m'a fait penser à
une carreaux cannes avec 40 points f5
qui ressemble beaucoup à une prépa mais
c'est scandinave dam des systèmes et un
bien fait de me dire cristal quand tu es
seul des fois du coup tu ta défaite à
des visions comme ça qui arrive c'est
vrai que ça se ressemble tellement la
structure
ok ça menace f5 là quand même genre tu
peux pas faire pousser 5 3 h 2 rock il
doit y avoir f5 encore que ça ça peut
continuer là bas mais ça va aller pour
les blancs mais bon faut quand même
faire gaffe aux caisses et cinq femmes
une question peut-être le roi évacuer
les camions h un je ne sais pas mais bon
h1 tu t'exposes à lui des quatre dames
ces six banques et maintenant est-ce que
rock et un coup phil alan parce que si
ça c'est possible
aussi bizarre que ça puisse paraître
quel est le coût pour les blancs ici
j'aurais eu aucune confiance avec les
noirs que ça marche mais l'ordi des dix
gagnants pour les noirs je n'ai pas
vérifié je pensais que les noirs étaient
foutues mais rock était jouable elle
fait h5 f5 et fouet fch 7 c'est bien
joué aussi
elle aurait quand même pu prendre angers
4 à mon avis le roi blanc est tellement
aux fraises champions prend qui on prend
et f5
j'ai l'impression que tout reproche
trois rivaux prochain ça pouvait se
tenter à mon avis
parce que là le problème c'est que c'est
pas clair qu'elle est le roi le plus
faible maintenant ce que lui rend que
jamais donc tour à elle protège le pion
aux 5
il faut prendre ces trois je pense bête
d'un procès trois dames f2 peut-être sa
rente de partout même en quoi faire
dames ces deux hommes dames français de
du coût d'emprunt ces trois dames fz1
prend ces deux études et fend en gagnant
les pions du ku'damm france 3 c'est un
vrai coup candidat parce que c'est un
coup défensif
non seulement ça prend un pion mais en
plus tu veux te défendre dans les coups
défensifs la tour f 8 aussi donc elle
prend ces trois dames b 5 grammes c6
prise prise et elle va faire tour b 1
et elle va faire tourner cette course
est ok mais faut f5 des rois et fuite
qu'elle a tout calculé kosteniuk et tour
f3 ok ça l a pas vu jusque là mais à
tout reprend ses six fougue 4 qu'elle
fait tout rue89 est fou et 4 à première
vue mais tours 8 pas idiot non plus elle
a vite calculé un kosteniuk talent avait
tout vu elle a tout reprendre sinclar
wife quatre peut-être tête il fallait
quand même faire fou de cas je sais pas
mais d'avoir peur que le pion avance
donc ai apris prisa est fou 17 encore
elle a calculé un peu plus loin elle
joue pas mal hein
et ça c'est juste nul prise à cette
prise machin on rentre avec le roi on va
mettre le ranger 3 pions ces trois fous
des 4 du coup on est sur noir et on peut
juste prémisse fois je suis fou des
quatre essais nul 1-1 une nouvelle fois
j'ai l'impression que c'est plutôt les
noirs qui qui sont pas passés loin mais
c'était bien rue adam prend dame b 5
pour b1 est là juste à la vitesse de
l'éclair comprend g4 f5 tu es bien joué
aussi mais elle a eu le tour prend 1,6
elle avait tout calculé elle calcule sur
le temps de l'adversaire c'est pour ça
que si la tonne ce qui re pouvait
légèrement accéléré si elle pouvait
légèrement accéléré ça pourrait faire
une différence parce que du coup elle
aurait plus le temps matériel de l or et
plus le temps matériel de calculer sur
son temps et ça ferait une grosse
différence
ça le fait juste légèrement accéléré
mais bon c'est qu'elle peut pas le faire
ainsi elle le fait pas c'est juste
qu'elle peut pas le faire
parce que ce qu'est ce qui lui manque
c'est un poil de vitesse mais bon la
vitesse et du niveau de jeu mais comme
kosteniuk calcul sur son temps ça le
truc c'est qu'elle calcule sur son temps
et c'est vrai que c'est ça ça fait une
différence
donc on est reparti et on a des pions
pendant à la sortie de cette ouverture
des quatre alors ça évidemment ça fait
bill pioncer 5 qui maintenant est
arriérée mais ça donne la casse ces
trois donc c'est intéressant peut-être
cavaliers à 4 du coup le retour est
jouable pour contre la casse c3 et s'en
prendre à ces cinq sur quoi faut un peu
calcul est fou et vous c'est si sa
cavale et aux cinq mètres carrés l'idée
de intéressant pour échanger
intéressant
ça permettrait d'échanger pas mal de
matériel et ça ça doit de faciliter la
vie avec avec les blancs après avoir un
mais ce serait vraiment un coup que ge
envisagerait personnellement c'est un
coût qui me paraît intéressant après pas
dit que ce soit le meilleur 1
c'est un coût qui me plairait perçoit
finalement est tu t'en prends au
cavalier fait dam des trois bons
faisable aussi mais québec a té d'ambea
ok mais cahill et 2 c'est quoi le
problème fondamental je sais pas
peut-être f5 sur quel est des deux déjà
j'ai passé un cap 5 et bien jouer qui
est né de f5 c'était peut-être un
problème bon avoir jeu honnêtement j'en
sais rien honnêtement je n'en sais rien
bon alors ok qui se retrouvent en c3
ouais donc les noirs qui ont réussi à
apprendre la casse et 3m qui cassent tu
penses que tu as apporté en vite sur ce
format là non je pense qu'elle est plus
forte que moi sur ce format là parce
qu'elle est mieux préparée dans les
ouvertures donc je pense qu'au début je
peux faire illusion mais après j'aurais
des problèmes dans les ouvertures
donc je ferai pas je ferais pas illusion
très longtemps
elle me battrait way malek il ya eu des
doigts il fallait jouer à gafsa 1 cave
s'inquiétait était probablement le coup
ff iii metz cafu et 4
j'aurais tellement tenté de faire flouer
4 et sur dame c4 ou des cinq le
fousseret mieux placés en d5 ski
tapissier et si la dame bouche tu
ramènes ta d'amendé 5 et tu t'en prends
aux cavaliers après faut calculer un
mais taf d'abc quatre fous des cinq
dames détroit le retour ok c'est ça
l'idée parce que elles menacent le pion
des 4 et si tu prends des 3l prend ici
tu as tu dois prendre nul ouais c'est ce
que c'est ce que je calcule et quand
j'avais fouet 4 après donc à l'aise si
on prend des 4 ha ha puis on prend des 4
puis on prend des quatre cavaliers prend
des quatre points des quatre cavaliers
deux prises non en soi que je pensais
qu'il prend des quatre ce qu'elle veut
faire dame prend en compte les dames
prend des cats et cava lieu de tout
vêtement pour ça j'avais vu mais sur
cavaliers prend des quatre tours prend
ses seins et c'est fini saab endroit
fouet f1 forcé iaf ou price 3 et surtout
rien on prend un et on prend là mais je
sais pas ce qui se passait sur qu'elle
prend des cats j'ai essayer de vite
mettre leur dit non non c'est pas cette
élection j'ai pas réussi puisque ça j'ai
vu là venant prendre et 4e 2 c'était le
piège
j'ai promis au lieu de 4 est il possible
j'ai pas j'ai pas eu le temps de
regarder cristal mais possible tu vois
il ya des tactiques qui sont ratés de
partout donc c'est possible qu'ils aient
des petites des petites tactiques à la
dame peu apprise par la tour c 8 autant
pour moi oui l'homme s'était perdons
dans tous les cas
autant pour moi mais sa santé que l
avant et 4 que j'avais eu le temps de le
voir mais le tactile est pas j'ai pas
encore j'allais pas encore récupéré et
puisqu'ils font 1 4 du coup les carottes
sont cuites
bon ça va repartir avec cette idée alors
tout à l'heure la veille mis le foin h67
fois ci pourquoi n'a pas fait que x h 6
ha ok elle a fait cavalier aussi
s'arranger si cette fois-ci tout à
l'heure elle avait attendu de fer g6 et
elle avait fait après le plan avec
cavaliers aussi celle elle a fait avant
mais les blancs qui vont répéter le plan
à 4 4 et 5 qui est vraiment fort dans
cette position c'est un bon plan ça dans
la structure carlsbad avec lecavalier
ont eu deux là d'envoyer f4 f5
c'est vraiment intéressant mais à l'oeuf
et gaiement donc elle va de nouveau
sacrifiés du matériel elle m'a envoyé la
calotte juste par curiosité c'est fou
prend un f5 c'est quoi le truc c'était
assez bien envoyé une kalach un jeu
juste regarder rien qu'à l'idée c'est
bien évidemment d'envoyer un message est
que c'est sympa pour les blancs il ya la
tour qui arrive en f1 et il ya beaucoup
de jeux sur le roi ça doit être très
bien ça pour les blancs donc du coup
elle fait ses 6es carélie g3
c'est 5 hockey
ok c'est chaud prisa six sprints 6 qui
prises des 5 dame prend des 5es va voir
fouet 4 c'est encore une faute tactique
de la part de la tonne ce qui a qui ne
voit plus rien ok il faut essayer
d'avoir fois ci sans fin de variantes
faut essayer de repartir avec la dame
mais sur part avec la dame torah non ça
peut aller tu reprendras de f 5 x 6 le
fou revient et tu prendras à 8 mais bon
c'est trop lent en fait elle joue trop
lentement elle via un intermédiaire
c'est bien joué
ok là la question ça peut être ça reste
que tu prends un f6 intermédiaires je
pense pas à tu laisses c'est quoi que
non mais j'y crois pas je pense tu
reviens avec le fou ils prennent tu
prends mais ils vont prendre des 4l
prend un f6 du coup on imagine est
imaginé un premier tour prend jouable
aussi oui puisque comme ça et pas fou
des cinq échecs elle reprend la tour des
six alors matériellement on en est où il
ya égalité matérielle pour le moment
mais le pion à n en mai le roi noir est
plus faible les trois échecs
je comprends pas trop la plus value pour
le mans leur donner cet échec à risque
quelle est l'idée d'ardam b3 parce qu'en
vérité du coup le roi noir est mieux
placé manquait
elle a dû penser qu'ils aient quelque
chose avec le roi bien placé n'est
peut-être pas forcément si bien et
peut-être tour d un ici pour échanger
les pièces je pas l'impression que le
roi noir est tout de même un peu moins
bien ce qu'elle tue angers 6 qui avance
et je pense que les blancs sont mieux
ici mais bien un meilleur roi
donc vous pouvez changer les pièces avec
les noirs est allé faire nul c'est ce
qu'elle est en train de faire qui
essayent change
est ce vraiment échanges et aurait pu
faire tout re 8 et d'apprendre des trois
ne sais pas grand intérêt avec les
blancs et l'a peut-être tour des uns ne
protège son pion
ce que t'as pas envie de faire dame des
quatre échecs auxquels fait tourner en
maintenant qu'est ça arrive à lui de
faire le coup d'avant parce que du coup
dans le port apparent h2 maintenant tu
es moins bien c'est pas du tout la même
que tourner un le coup d'avant parce que
tourner un le coup d'avant c'est pas
c'est pas du tout la même
ok maintenant il va falloir souffrir la
dharma ou 5 est très bien placé parce
qu'elle couvre le roi et les attaques de
l'autre côté
bon ça a l'air d'aller la géométrie des
pièces noires est pas mauvaise quand
même mais elle s'est mis en semi
difficulté
sept cavaliers f5 ici on l'achète je
pense qu'il ya qu'à valider cette qui
est chiant
quoique parce que tu peux avoir du
rebond f8 donc un relief 5 elle a réussi
à faire
ok
elle est un peu vis ces dames h8 aurait
pu peut-être arrivée mais ave damage 7
qui couvre donc elle peut échanger les
dames et faire cavalier c5 dès
maintenant problem is est inquiet mais
prendre le pion h c'est à mon avis un
peu nan ça va non non ça va ça va aller
juste à temps et sur trois les cavaliers
ces deux échecs il ya toujours cavalier
ces deux sur trois kessé 2 qui apprend à
3 en plus à protéger le pion cas la
question c'est ce que tu dois faire j'ai
quatre auquel cavaliers qui revient mais
qui a laissé 4 qui couvre la case non
c'est laisser les noirs qui vont gagner
ici
roy g5 bien jouer diagonale par rapport
aux cavaliers et maintenant il va y
avoir h 3 h 2 h un rsa va filer à 3
c'était vraiment il ya eu plusieurs
erreurs de la part des blancs allez ça
fait plaisir elle revient à moi + 4 elle
revient en moins car est très réussi à
stabiliser mais il aurait pu faire
peut-être qui a été sept cavaliers fuite
quand il rachète sa part et c'est hyper
dangereux
ça paraissait vraiment dangereux
l'autre dû fait retour des 1 avant h3
sap a été très bien et très bon et c'est
le répertoire facile ok la joue sans
jouer fou g5 intéressant bonsoir magique
kotick dans le tchat
à 8-7 fou g5
mettre le fond g5
ça à tout va
et donc sa semi transpose parce que
cette tour en est vraiment bien placé
j'aimerais bien faire d'un f4 damache 4
mais je pense que c'est répondu par food
et 6 d'un match 4 tours b 4
cette tourbe et qu'elle anticipe la
menace sur le pion qui va arriver
les noirs qui recule et qu'ils donnent
la case b4 pour la tour à tour b4
maintenant mais elle veut faire c'est 3
/ tour des quatre elle a bien anticipé
tour b 4 elle a pas mal joué du tout
avec les blancs donc l accueil des
quatre maintenant tu attaques sur ses 6
et sur dame ces sept là vous prend h6 le
petit chipeau sakho c'est mieux qu'à les
voir tous ces trucs là tu peux faire
confiance
donc faut peut-être commencer par fou
prend f4 puisque sûr qu'elle prend ses
six états d'âme c'est cette jeunesse que
tu peux
en quelle pensée pour sa prise prises et
maintenant peut-être dame 17 bêtement ou
dams et 8,5 et p3 j'aime pas peut-être
b4 il fallait faire mais pas b3
p3 j'ai pas trop aimé je trouve ça un
peu mou b4 pour essayer de prendre de
l'espace la tapa fouet f5 puisque à tour
prendre un sur échec mais peut-être il
fallait faire quand même
je m'étais un peu de pression je sais
pas j'ai pas envie de critiquer parce
qu'elle fait une bonne partie elle avait
un bon plan elle est bien sortie de
l'ouverture mais après c'est un peu
[Musique]
ok elle va vouloir jouer pour pour pour
fixer ce pion là ok c 4 c'est bien joué
dans mais elle est mieux quand même ce
que des 4 tu bloques tout sur noir et on
fout blanc va rayonner
ok donc elle touche à rien kosteniuk
c'est évidemment ce qu'il fallait faire
google qui nous répond c'est pas nous
aider mais elle fait dam des 6es du coup
elle à pavie c'est la case de 5,7 à me 3
voile réussi quand même avis et elle va
réussir à faire f4 non elle réussit
quand même à visser mais à la wayne ans
elle a quand même obtenu un avantage là
bien transformer j'ai pensé qu'elle peut
obtenir plus mais peut-être qu'en
réalité elle a très bien joué donc à et
17 pour jouer 5
voilà je pense f4 un tu dois de toute
façon prendre l'espace que tu peux aussi
faire peut-être pions prend puis on
prendra moins huit cavaliers f8 n'y a
rien que tu fasses f4 alors mais faut
juste que tu un peu plus vite
elle se serait bien qu'elle gagne pour
le spectacle
ça prend trop de temps entre temps et
kosteniuk elle se nourrit de ça là on
voit pas comment qui aimait dams est
peut-être jusqu'à vallier
quoique quoique à chaque fois il me fait
mentir
c'est peut-être bien jouer ce qu'elle a
fait
c'était bien parce qu'elle pion à 7 qui
rôdent enfin deux variantes la dame
recettes qui est bien placé il ya un tas
de problèmes de maths du couloir il
s'arrête sur car il ya ici ça juste dame
prend à 7 est la huitième rang g et
super faible non là elle va gagner
ça me prend à s'être va arriver qu'elle
fait à me prendre et sisteron des six f4
qu'est ce que c'est que ça soit je
comprends rien ok non il leur dit donne
bien à me prends à s'être comme le
meilleur coût non mais c'est incroyable
en fait c'est que tu te dis à la super
bien je parce qu'elle a vu tout ça est
en fait après tu te demandes si c'était
pas du hasard qua non mais là quand même
falloir tout l'idée de damas est sa
table set ça repose sur le fait que
cavalia fille qui la dame prend à 7
en fait ça repose tous là dessus sinon
c'est mauvais des frais des trucs que je
suis pas faim quand tu joues bien et que
tu rates l'idée principale de ce que tu
as joué on se demande si ce n'était pas
de la pure chance quand même après il a
peut-être viala peut-être pété un plomb
mais c'est quand même spécial avec 15
secondes sur sur la pendule eux c'est
étrange quoi je comprends pas
franchement je comprends pas tu
comprends pas parce que c'est eiffage
suis déçu je suis déçu pour elle parce
qu'elle fait elle fait le boulot elle
joue bien et tout mais après elles
ratent à elle rappelé idée de ce qu'elle
a joué sur ça après tu dis est ce que
est ce que c'était vraiment volontaire
ou pas bon allez faut quand même quel la
gagne attention ouais mais là là là
maintenant elle est en train de se faire
dépasser donc et je pense heureusement
qu'il ya pas le roi qui est rentrant
j'ai cinq vastes et plus possible ce qui
avait h 4 et la liane roy qui va rentrer
angers 5
non pas encore maintenant le roi va
rentrer angers 5 kg 5 c'est bien joué
faire cavalier 4 et maintenant le roi va
rentrer angers 5 ou même encore pire la
tour en c1 et la finale de pions et
gagnante hockey avait tout reprendre et
entreprenait un cavalier f2 qui prend
des rois g5 qui gagnait qui a été ratée
je crois et du coup ça c'est nul
va-t-on violents à 6 et c'est nul je
veux juste revenir pour voir voilà il y
avait tout reprend fou prend cavaliers
cheikh croit prend cavaliers prend droit
prend airois g5 qui était complètement
gagnant qui était quand même assez
simple donc c'est pas mal on va revenir
au direct et ça c'est nul n'est pas tout
c'est de gagner la tournée yahia pu voir
plein de trucs raté
ok elle tombe non mais au pied mais
qu'est ce que c'est
non mais tu rates dame prend à ceinture
à tsahal qui rate le gars enfin la cité
le festival les amis c'était le festival
non mais en fait de dame prend à sète où
tu gagnes et tu reviens à -3 tu perds ça
et tu repasses à moins 5 m et c'est
dommage parce qu'en fait on peut on
n'est pas loin d'avoir du suspense on
n'est pas loin d'avoir un match
homérique et il ya trop de vendanges
il ya trop de vendanges les ventes en
jeu c'est en automne c'est pas
maintenant tu fais les vendre maintenant
c c c koi tu tues tu vas pas réussir à
faire de 20 la lave est là tu vas
ratures du tata même pas du jus de
raisin là t'as rien du tout là c'est
qu'est ce que c'est que ce à quoi
non mais c'est pas ce n'est pas la
période des vendanges s'étouffe avalait
vendanges c'est en automne c'est
septembre maintenant c'est un peu août
avec le réchauffement le réchauffement
climatique
ça peut commencer fin août et ça ça peut
aller jusqu'à fin octobre début novembre
mais c'est pas c'est pas à mimer la
caisse que qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
qu'elle me fait cesser les américains ça
ils savent pas faire du bon vin
lc sur six iep rennes longtemps à
l'avance ça ça va pas le faire les mecs
non mais je vais au bout d'un moment
voilà enfin on a envie on a envie de on
a envie de voir des remonte à dakwa on
n'a pas envie de devoir n'importe quoi
qu'est ce que c'est que ça allez vous
prend hcr khaimah ça marche pas non mais
ça perd sur des finales
ça ça se perd et leïla elle était pas
moins bien autant rien il ya zéro
excuses je sais pas ce qu'elle fait j'ai
pas ce qu'elle fait les mecs je
comprends pas en fait à les dames des
quatre envois ya packard a lieu de y'a
rien à l'est à oui mais non mais on est
pour l'autre en fait
mince c'est que ces nus comme on aime
bien bossé newaucun mais on veut on veut
une remonte à la tour prends un noir
reste solide peut-être trucs comme h4
qu'ariane 5 qui avait lieu 5
insolite et sec sur kate de5 avait
peut-être faire [ __ ] prend gaye 2 502
jouable et ses joues et d'ailleurs
qu'est qui les prend et là je pense
qu'elle va reprendre du pillon aller
c'est moche quand même et puisque et
nancy surprend du cavalier il y avait
quatre bêtement n'en reprend du cavalier
sort de questions il ya f4 est ok mais
tu as fait encore dame h4 tu peux
peut-être
tamazgha ce que je retiens est proche
ces trois projets 7 le pion f été cloué
mais peut-être un truc avec g3 machin
tourcoing 5
ok mais fait cavalier prendre 60 fait
pas cas il prend ses fils elle s'est
perdue fait cavalier prendra me prend et
réfléchi ces 5 mai à tours 8 échecs et à
me ranger cette eau là tu crois ma
tondeuse
[Musique]
non mais tu te demandes ce qui est
vraiment vu ou pas vu dans cette partie
je me dis ouais ça calcule loin et où sa
voix des trucs mais en fait c'est ce que
sa voix quoi que ce soit palmarès je me
suis pris en matant de nom mais là je
suis déçu les mecs
puis des zus quelle finalité tu prends
la call of super psy c'est ok si elle a
quelque chose à l tomates bravo enfin
mais de façon à un pion - sinon elle m'a
souri 8 m'attendais à rien ok tu prends
tu prends quoi
non mais ça arrive c'est une tarte ou
non mais elle est dans le dur mais bon
j'ai envie de dire il faudrait pouvoir
prendre un faire un timeout quoi tu es
et tu tu vas dans le bon et là tu as
stallone qui vient c'est comme dans
rocky quoi il vient et où comme comme
creed quoi creed dans le dernier match
quand il allait faire son match en
russie là dans celui qui vient de sortir
en blu ray il va en russie machin il
prend des coups je sais pas tu as
stallone qui lui dit fou est ce que tu
veux vraiment gagner ce combat tu as
enfin il est là stallone dont il jouit
je veux vraiment gagner ce combat bon
bah tu vas faire ce que tu sais faire tu
encaisse les coups machin et tu va le
mettre ko s'est pas tu prends un timeout
tu vois stallone par étapes
voilà la cia pas stallone qui vient td
c'est fini
kg catal se prendrait elle va se rendre
fou prend g4 qui étrangers quatre noms
mais la peur en plus maman elle a peur
chagrin l'eau
a peur
qui est cavalier h4 façon c'est sûr
qu'elle se prendre un truc
elle va devoir faire cavalier h 2 et
pourtant le fou en jk n'était pas
forcément bien placé 1
ça méritait peut-être h3g 4 rapide ou
peut-être fallait faire un truc comme à
bab et foot la dame
foot la dame en a huit ce que la l'autre
elle va attaquer comme comme une morte
de faim quoi c'est horrible
quoique bref la dame s'en était pas mal
qu'elle se barrent là bas mais ça va
non mais là elle a peur de tout
maintenant c'est fini
ça joue dans la tête maintenant elle
joue elle joue pas mal hein elle joue
pas mal
elle va chasser le fou le fou qui fait
rien là bas qu'elle valait h4 non mais
elle est bien elle est bien allé bien
faire cavalier f5
peut-être g5 et food et 5 passes et
quatre intermédiaires
ouais savoir rien ses calculs à rien
puis on prend un f6 aucune des deux
l'avait vu ça j'en prends des trois
pions pranger cette cavalière cinq
échecs tu es beaucoup mieux pas là tu
fais cavaliers f5 aller non mais là tu
as tout pour toi si elle prend pas elle
prendre cavale at à la tour qui arrive
en g3 dame f6 tu vas matez donc au pire
tu fais ab déjà pour commencer
airwatch de tours gère et tours j'ai
trois mais je commencerai par ab pour
voir peut-être faire maintenant tour g1
peut-être tout reprend à 8 et entend
aussi dames 6
ok c'est pas encore fini
mais mais une souris que tu apprends tu
à prendre ses pions détroit pourquoi tu
prends le pion b3 tu laisses du contre
je pourquoi tu mets pas une petite tour
en g3 avant une petit tour en f3 un
petit tour r3 le dame prend b3 juste un
petit tour f3 est la mieux placée
parce que maman elle te joue la finale
c'est pas gagné non mais ça manque de
samassa manque de précision là quand
même ça ça laisse du jeu et ça c'est pas
fini le 4 way f3 et touré tour à 2 ok
bon roi montrent bien joué les rois g73
f4f si ce qui étonnant peut-être relief
trois ça va changer mais larroy aussi je
pense très fort a mis à tour f3 tout
reprendre 4 pensée 3 n'en fallait faire
roi prend 2,4 ou pas ok tout recettes
bien joué tour bessette bien joué ok là
les noirs ont du mal à défendre
il faut mettre le roi en des quelque
chose
tourbes et quatre peut-être qui sait
tellement bizarre de parfaits pour les
quatre qu'elle
roy g77 faut revenir parce que si tu
viens on sait 8 je pense que les noirs
ils vont faire nul mais non mais non
maintenant il ya roigé 6 mai un oeil à
tour ses sept tours c'est cette gagne
non ça gagner pas mais oui à roye b 8
mais oui mais bien sûr mais là fallait
juste faire rager six des huit d'am-dam
h5 et tu pousses le pion et c'est pas
sûr du tout que les blancs puis
s'arrêter touré cheick willeroise bave
tour c'est ça ça marchait pas et b2 mais
ils voient bien 8 tous les dix huit sur
échec
ok mais c'est la nôtre qui a gagné
non enfin on souffre en finale dans ce
matin on souffre selah sue frada les
amis c'est dur
c'est dur ça nous fait souffrir
bon allez ça relance un peu le match
mais on a un peu on souffre un peu dans
ce match on suit on souffre avec cana en
fait on aimerait bien que on aimerait
bien avoir du suspense à l est pas loin
ça joue à pas grand chose là encore elle
a souffert un pour gagner il aurait pu
se refaire retourner mais ça et que je
suis 3g 6 d'am-dam h5 procès 3g 5 qui
est peut-être le roy revenait de
justesse mais avait un temps à perdre
pour aller chercher le pion b du coup
c'était dur à évaluer bon j'aime
vraiment bien le système de kosteniuk
contre la petrov franchement je vais le
tester
du coup je suis quelqu'un qui trottent
dans le tchat ce que jouer avec les
derniers messages m'ont vraiment je vois
pas de troll personnellement si c'est le
cas je donnerai mes joies pas d' insulte
ou quoi gt gt gt complètement dans la
partie dans la déception donc est ce
qu'il y avoir 4 5
qui est des cinq c'est bien joué parce
que maintenant le problème des violences
qui peuvent pas jouer aux quatre pas ils
peuvent jouer 4 mais ils vont perdre la
paire de fou auquel il rend vraiment
positif quoique le rv est faible
j'y crois pas je crois pas une seconde
mais bon peut-être que je me trompe pas
un c'est plus que possible
c'est plus que possible
peut-être qu'à y prend 1,4 je vois pas
vraiment où est le problème je vois pas
je prends le prêt vital quel point
cadjee mettre le jus mais tu leur dis
que peut-être que moi aussi j'hallucine
maintenant ok cac et prend 1,4 et l île
numéro 1 de l'ordi de loin et l'ordi
disait coin là dessus ok fois h61 hockey
joué pour l'activité mais la justesse ça
et je comprends avoir fait mais fou
prend 1,4 c'est juste tellement logique
ok là il n'ya pas cavalier pranger 6 non
non il yal j'hallucine mais bon en
revenant d'une position à l'autre ça
fait halluciner
les sept patients et c'est juste
tellement bizarre de pas repris 1,4
donc donc donc
ok mais le roi blanc est quand même très
faible non mais ça pour les juges
étaient choqués adams et 7
mais le roi blanc est forcément faible
il n'y a pas grand chose devant le roi
un coup comme dame sait si c'est
intéressant qui sait d'un v6 vise la
case 3 vise le pion cavalli jessains mes
copines qu'elle joue bien ses positions
après même quand elle est mal
ok cavaliers trois prises et foot et je
pensais qu'elle ferait fou des cinq
échecs intermédiaire je suis étonné en
fait surtout prend 3 qu'elle n'est pas
intercalé food et 5
là encore ça paraissait très logique jeu
mais je vais leur dis parce qu'en fait
je ne sais pas si c'est moi qui
hallucine complètement et qui racontent
n'importe quoi
bref des cinq premiers coups de leur dis
encore une fois en fait je mes lordi
dans ces cas là parce que c'est des
coups qui me paraissent tellement
logique
parlant de décision un peu bizarre après
ça a très bien joué pendant pendant 1h30
2h c'est peut-être un peu la fatigue et
le manque de confiance parce que elle a
très bien joué
anna est peut-être ça il ya un petit
coup de mou td deux joueuses parce que
jusqu'à maintenant on n'a pas du tout eu
à se plaindre de la qualité du jeu
c'était plutôt bien bon
c'est un peu un peu de fatigue c'est
vrai que les matches sont usants mais
elle était tellement bien elle semble
être la bonne position et maintenant la
finale
elle est même un peu moins bien parce
que la tour blanche arrive en septième
et les pions noirs sont un peu déliées
alors ça doit se tenir mais ça va être
chiant à jouer pour les noirs c'est fou
par f5 n'a pas le temps autour des 7 à 5
la tour arrivant 17 c'est pénible mais a
poussé un ouf
très bien je vois ça c'est bien joué ça
c'est bien je vais pousser un comme ça
elle va échanger et auquel va faire nul
en sifflotant
ok elle a trouvé la bonne ressource
défensive h5 elle envoie son jeu il va y
avoir un retour c'est cette g5 elle
pourra mettre le ranger 6 avancer les
pions
elle s'est débarrassée de ce problème là
donc il faut qu'il passe devant elle m'a
envoyé elle va envoyer fc4 mais on va
pouvoir envoyer f5 le compte renvoyer le
pion je pense ouais c'est bien jouer
jusqu'à 4 f4 mal aurait pu échanger et
faire f 4 mais je pense que ça revient
sensiblement aux mêmes alors en revanche
ce fou est vraiment bien placé
ok tout rêve si sûr que tu prends là nul
très bien joué et rejoué
si on te la donne ok mais ça c'est
complètement nul donc et faire rager 6
c'est ça qu'on va choper le pion aux
quais encore watch quatre fous c'est un
fou et 4 donc avant ça c'est nul nul on
se tait minutes de l'autre côté mais
peut-être qu'avec le pion j'ai le roi
était du mauvais côté pour défendre et
peut-être une petite difficulté
on va juste revenir et ce qu'elle
pouvait garder le pion avec 3 h 4 way
elle pouvait garder les familles croates
4 parce qu'il est fou et quatre échecs
intermédiaires et ça aurait été un peu
chaud heureusement elle n'a pas vu ça
maintient un peu de suspense il reste
combien de temps as et la fin des trois
plus un c'est la fin des trois plus un
elle aurait pu être mais en léger danger
mais je crois que c'est cette roue de
couleur opposée à tes pas être super
dangereux et quand même tu préfère ne
pas avoir à la défendre donc à 12,7
mais bon c'est pas c'est pas si c'est
pas si violent violents comme comme
écart qui sait peut-être qu'elle peut
revenir l est pas
elle est moins loin que ce qu'on pensait
elle est un peu revenue elle pouvoir
regretter les deux trois parties elle
s'est fait mais il pourrait y avoir
genre que de trois points d'écart
honnêtement bon sur ce on va se mettre
une petite pub et on va on va on va on
revient dans 5 minutes à tous les mecs
ça de suite
[Musique]
bon les mecs il reste encore la pub on
va repartir pour la séance de bullet on
a moins 5 ça peut encore se faire
j'espère qu'il ya une remonte à da on
verra on verra on verra on verra on
verra
moi j'ai un peu le chat je pense qu'un
mec qui est pas content que je commente
les vannes membre coûte tu peux toujours
écrire à chess comme c'était pas content
c'est pas c'est pas grave je leur
propose une autre candidature quoi c'est
pas c'est pas un problème
une fusée il ya des gens qui aiment bien
les gens qui aiment pas comme comme a
dit le célèbre poète français booba si
tu kiffes pâte écoute pas et puis c'est
tout ça va pas plus loin
c'est pas grave moi je le prends pas mal
donc
donc donc donc on à daniel règne encore
en pub on a encore daniel reyne chant
pub et on va on va bientôt attaquer le
but la toile et on j'espère j'espère une
remontée à les focales se chauffe un peu
faut marquer des points
on va traiter les joueurs de pigeons à
ça j'ai pas vu sa mire l'uss mais foyer
un peu de condescendance soumettre les
gens qui jouent pas mal mais qui joue
pas très bien et c'est dommage
c'est dommage c'est comme si moi quand
j'allais jouer le matin au tennis les
gens se foutait de ma gueule parce que
je joue mal tu vois bon je suis très
heureux de jouer au tennis ça me fait
plaisir je prends du plaisir c'est tant
mieux j'espère que c'est la même chose
que c'est la même chose pour vous on est
là pour s'amuser un les échecs les
échecs c'est un jeu et je sais pas il ya
peut-être des gens qui ont envie de
faire autre chose de de leur vie que je
joue aux échecs tout le temps pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas à fin juillet
heureusement qu'il ya du contenu pour
pour les gens qui ont juste envie de
s'amuser
qui fait quoi toi tu as et gramsci quand
tu vas au tennis tu as que des cours ou
du contenu pour les pros thomas je
regardais roland garros tout à l'heure
c'est un spectacle c'est pour tout le
monde quoi tu étais là pour t'amuser
donc c'est ça en fait l'objectif c'est
le délire c'est pas c'est ni plus ni
moins c'est pas de faire du contenu pour
pour les 50 grands maîtres enfin quoique
quoique quand on a fait les trucs avec
vlad pour le championnat du monde et où
c'était quand même très high level donc
y en a un peu pour tout le monde mais
bon là on est là pour s'amuser pour
regarder un show en plus le niveau de
jeu est pas exceptionnel honnêtement là
c'est on n'est pas en train de suivre
une finale de championnat du monde à
anla compris ça joue pas super bien au
delà pour passer un bon moment il est
dimanche 20h57 jour d'élection chez le
cheval n'aime pas les résultats je m'en
fiche je m'en contrefiche donc
tranquille on est juste là pour passer
un bon dimanche ensemble passer de trois
heures ensemble finir la semaine demain
on va tous au taf
on est juste là pour eux pourquoi on un
peu de
un peu de plaisir
avant de repartir pour une nouvelle
semaine et il y aura un jour férié jeudi
jour du match de ce bac d'ailleurs
puisque ça me permet de rebondir
donc voilà le délire après n'apprenez
pas tous obligés d'aimer ou quoi enfin
ça c'est le droit de tout un tout un
chacun c'est le droit de tout un chacun
bon et vendredi donc le match qu on
commentera avec maxime bon là du coup et
peut-être que ça suffira en terme de
niveau mais on ne sait pas on verra on
verra ce que ça vaut et jeudi avec fab
et vendredi avec maxime et demain aussi
demain demain demain demain je sais même
pas qui joue pour vous dire la vérité a
tellement de stream en fait que je me
rappel des dates importantes georges e
10 e bagh se bagarrent ica et vendredi
ou et ypres à galandage les tellement dû
le dire que je l'a appris par coeur et
demain je sais plus qui s'est donc
alors non plus commenter ce n'est pas
une question niveau nettement quand vous
regarder du foot par exemple c'est pas
les deux commentateurs s'est passé pas
moins zidane et griezmann ou un zidane
mbp bon peu importe l on est parti pour
le bullet il reste il reste trente
minutes de jeu et c'est les 30 minutes
qui peuvent tous décidé à t'inscrire
dominé dans ce match dominé dans les ait
note qui peut peut-être retourner la
situation à la moins 5 l/ha semble être
un peu dans le dur moi je dirais
physiquement un petit peu un petit peu
comme un manque d'énergie menaçante sur
la fin mais kosteniuk était pas au mieux
non plus après trois heures de jeu les
niveaux peuvent se niveler c'est un peu
le cinquième set on sait pas ce qui peut
arriver
il ya peut-être des crampes ya peut-être
quelque chose donc les noirs qui
contrôle bien le centre avec les pions
e6 f5 à diagonale blanche qui est bien
contrôlé les blancs qui sont visés
qu'ils peuvent pas faire 4 et s'il peut
elle réussir à progresser au centre ils
seront obligés dé changer le fou de
cases blanches un fou qui est une de
leurs pièces maîtresses donc comment
progresser comment bouger le centre ici
avec les blancs on va le voir est ce
qu'elle va jouer un petit coup de hache
quatre fous g5 alors bouger le pion à
jeter un petit conseil pour les gens qui
font un peu de bullet ça peut quand tu
sais pas quoi faire là c'est un peu
perdu tu envoies h4h si ça te fait
toujours gagner une seconde pour penser
peut-être un jour tu as une prise
d'espacé voilà c'est plate manon et le
conseil me disent tu sais pas quoi faire
des fois avancé le pur h
ça te fait toujours ça te sauve un peu
de temps donc dame b 3 elle a mis un peu
de pression dames 8 et on voit que la
les noirs ont bien réussi à prendre le
contrôle du centre là avec les blancs
elle cherche une idée pour faire quelque
chose de constructif et de former le
seul truc qu'elle fait c'est de faire
descendre sa pendule e3 peut-être elle
se résout à faire du cavalier d2 mais
elle aurait pu jouer cette idée là en
fait en quelques secondes
maintenant elle se prend tout sur le roi
kosteniuk qui est une joueuse
expérimentée en bulles est allé je pense
qu'il faut envoyer du c5 faut faire
quelque chose faut contrer ces cinq fort
sera un peu des 5es laférois j'ai
infligées cette dame des 3l va venir
colmatée le roi l'a toujours cavalier
enfin pour colmater le problème c'est
vraiment qu'elle s'est mis mal autant
mais y'a une seconde de rage où tout est
faisable pour eux deux elle va y avoir
la tour qui arrive en 1 h 6 mais c'est
rien le pion qui par an aux cinq qui on
prend à lecavalier qui arrive en 5e ça
fait mal il ya le cavalier qui menacent
de rentrer en f3 lecavalier f3 ya roi h1
latour couvre tout mais ya là bien là
tout compris s'ils avaient tous rendez
aux prises il y avait la tour
aux prises les amis il y avait la tour
de emprise elle était prenable sa tour
je crois bien ça pas été vus 3f 2e car
il est proche de b3 qu'est ce que c'est
que ça qu'est ce que c'est que ce coupé
3 c'est étrangement le roi qui repart
vers le centre on sait pas comment elle
a survécu sahara auquel veut four b2
pour contrer donc il ya eu la tour
emprise avait des trucs qui sont ce
qu'ils sont passés de partout j'ai
sûrement raté un milliard de trucs mais
on n'a pas trop le temps donc fou baie
de cavalière 6 alors est ce qu'on va
faire dame c6 oui
la dame qui vient se placer qui bloque
les pions kosteniuk qui qui cherche qui
ne trouvent pas comment conclure pour le
moment et du coup elle ce même à l'otan
mais lecavalier ont le cas très bien
placé d'armes français cet échange le
roi blanc est tellement mal
la dame qui vient peut-être tourache de
pour menacer maths c'est pas très
discret mais c'était pour créer une
menace alliage et 3 qui tombe sur échec
et ça va être fini roue en f1 dame j'ai
un math et tous rêvent de dames f de
domination totale de cossé new qui s'est
même permis au passage le rater une tour
en 1 est ok donc prochaine partie causé
nuke qui repart à une petite scandinaves
et loire veut être ferme et anne decis
et ouais c'est juste dommage de l'apamad
jouer jusqu'à a pris trop de temps
elle aurait pu elle aurait pu faire
qu'il y avait deux trois cavaliers des
deux qui étaient un peu un plan éco plus
elle aurait pu
elle aurait pu le faire plus vite c'est
dommage après c'était pas c'était pas
mais c'est pas sa cadence c'est pas sa
cadence on voit qu'elle aime bien
réfléchir qu'elle aime bien prendre son
temps elle joue bien quand elle prend
son temps mais elle n'arrive pas à jouer
des petits coups des petits coups comme
ça ok donc à chis fou des deux fous j'ai
si cela elle s'est bien remis elle joue
vite
las quand 10 1 pouces et 3 auquel se
replacent peut-être un coup comme dame
de elle va se placer avec ses pièces
bon ok mais là faut trouver un plan
toujours mon tour d un tu places les
pièces ça kosteniuk savez quel sens bien
ce truc là ok je t'envoie tu joues
cafouille 5,45 et changer un peu les
pièces
tu prends un peu moqué de façon
d'échanger puis tu classe sépia sauce
entame ans elle va sûrement faire un
petit coup de pouce et 3 voilà elle
revient elle joue assez vite ça va
échanger en c5 j'imagine une rage de
elle va peut-être se barrer fou proches
ouah c'est bien vu ça fout pranger cette
eau qui avait dame prend 2,5 il y avait
eu cinq surprise et du coup ça rentre
dans un échange massif elle tape à 7 à
la fin est bien vu le petit fou projet
satah joué beaucoup de coups automatique
et après la place et la petite tactique
elle est réelle et pas mal c'est ça la
différence c'est qu'elle sent bien la
cadence et elle joue elle joue vite des
petits quoi l'économie et hop là des
petits pièges et des petites tactiques
c'est ce qui l'a fait gagner maintenant
d'un médecin quel échange les pièces
elle va sûrement faire un petit coup
deux à quatre baies 3 peut-être pas sûr
pas obligé tour f1 bien joué alors
maintenant il va falloir progresser h4
pour jouer h5 si tu fais h5 le pion il
est sur blanc il va se faire attaquer
donc elle prendre l'espace avec les
noirs ajoute c4 elle veut contre
attaquer la tour en d2 il y aura tous
rêvent de tours bien placé elle colle
macho tour g4 ok sur wajdi autour des 2
tours 3 protège bien tour des deux tours
f2 et tour d un rouage de elle réussit à
se placer sur tours 1 1 il ya trois
tours à 4 à 3 aux 6es avec les noirs il
semble qu'elle réussisse pas à créer de
menaces est l'atout blindés maintenant
on va mettre la marche avant avec les
blancs peut-être faire un petit coup de
foulage ses impôts que je pensais qu'ils
allaient faire flasher s'inquiète g4
donc h5 elles limitent sa tour d2 tout
rêve de tour rentrer il faut mettre la
marche avant maintenant avec les blancs
fouet 3 tours 5 ha va sûrement ramener
son roi petit à petit nom fu g2 pour le
moment autour des tours détours trois
bouquets tourner trois pas vraiment
menace sur la toujours tour f3 c'est pas
facile de mettre la marche avant elle
fait à 4 elle commence à envoyer deux
pions autour des 7 tours un ace et bien
joué ça elle a vraiment bien joué
kosteniuk elle a passé la tour 1 elle
remet le fond f3 elle tourne bien f5
pour jouer du fouet 8 peut-être à 5 4 ok
je pensais qu'ils étaient faux 8 pour
aller taper le pion à mais elle fait eux
5 4 mais maintenant il ya roi e3 et les
pions sont bloqués sur blanc elle va
pouvoir faire b3 ou même b4 envoyait a5
a6 assez bien joué ça le pion qui
arrivant à 6 et qui va permettre d'avoir
torah 5 échecs pour les blancs ok même
ton à cinq là du coup parce que c'est
sûr échec le pion qui va aller jusqu'en
à 7
et ça va y aller donc c'est aussi le
plus rage 5 qui tombe elle a pas mal
joué elle a bien réussi à ceux à se
recroqueviller et elle a tout défendu en
fait à la mi à tour en f1 f2 le fou en
g2 et y avait plus aucune cible pour les
noirs du coup c'était même pas c'était
même pas facile à jouer pour les normes
ce que tu avais rien à attaquer et puis
après tout doucement est là elle a mis
la marche avant et tour à 4 c'était
vraiment bien joué peut-être fou 1,8 à
un moment donné aurait été plus
résistant je ne sais pas mais ça avait
l'air ça avait l'air de toute façon
d'être
c'était compliqué pour les noirs l'ail
est un mystique clairement avec 3 f1
c'est pas si grave
c'est toujours pénible mais c'est pas le
mythe clic le plus grave n'a pas donné
de matériel donc là on a qu au score on
n'a plus cette pour kosteniuk dont +7
c'est un gros écart et il reste 22
minutes de jeu ouais ça va à mon avis
être gagné assez facilement par par
kosteniuk qui ont 100 a beaucoup plus
d'expérience en bullet que son
adversaire dont il ya eu des cas tu es
fou prend f6 ok donc sur calais prend
dimpre ans il y aurait eu un problème
avec le pion cavalier e 4 donc elle va
essayer de faire quelque chose avec les
blancs hockey que ces trois qui est
qu'ils se barrent dame prend menace le
pion f5 et et des deux qu'elle va
revenir grand roque et il ya le pion
détroit qui est mal mais bon c'est vrai
qu'en perdant 2 tempo avec laurent plus
peut-être qu'elle voulait jouer 3g 2
plutôt que roi géant ici je sais pas
tabler plutôt mettre l'orangé 2 donc tu
puta talent a fait un double missclick
avec le roi et c'est vrai que quand tu
as perdu
en gros tu de voir la tour en f1 et un
coup de plus ça fait qu'à une grosse
différence
là il ya le pion b2 qui ce mois elle ne
prend pas parce qu'on sait jamais elle
préfère échanger les dames fait retour
des trois tours des 8es elle va jouer la
finale tranquille avec un pion de plus
qui est pas si simple que ça a gagné une
nouvelle fois c'est sait jamais si
facile que ça à gagner ces finales quand
les joueurs jouent bien en face ils se
défendent et c'est pas c'est pas si
facile à 5 peut-être à 4 et voulait
peut-être fait retour des trois
américains pour fixer mais peut-être b6
après le pion pouvait être protégé donc
cavalier des deux époux g5 f4 ça elle va
repartir en c4 avec le cavaliere bon
pour le moment elle fait travailler les
noirs au moins peut-être cavaliers ouais
ça peut-être pas à grand chose d'étroit
bien joué elle enlève le pion dans ses
solides et noir qui ont du mal à
progresser ici hein c'est pas évident à
progresser qui est donc elle va échanger
des pièces ou en tout cas essayer à 4
elle empêche toute velléité échangiste
j'ai envie de dire fou aux sept avoir
visé la casse bekkat c'est bien joué
elle elle commence à faire des petits
progrès la joue pas mal kosteniuk elle
joue vraiment pas mal du tout
donc le fou en b 4 bien placé et g4
entre temps fou des quatre cavaliers de
3 donc ça va un peu échangé et c'est
vrai qu'elle pions f5 qui reste mal donc
elle va prendre peut-être tour c4
maintenant à tour ses quatre tours d2
roi monté tour des trois arrêts moi
aussi je les ai vus avec un peu de
retard pour ces quatre qui avaient une
bonne tête mais qui a eu le problème de
tours d2 pour détroit et maintenant être
prendre les trois tours prend h trois
tours à 3 tours prend 1,4 au choix c'est
pas obligatoire à tour à 3 attentionné
kébé cinq échecs
c'est pour ça qu'elle a fait roi b6
avant tours c'est un tour ces trois
proposent les échanges droit qui est
bien placé en diagonale par rapport aux
cavaliers il ya le pion h cette emprise
un petit échec avant qui a validé trois
rois dessins qu'il va pas être bien
placé il ya un b 5 avec le cavalier f4
tombe h7 tombe trois c4 elle va aller
vers b3 pour aller prendre l'a4
ça paraît assez cool surtout que le
fourgon mines un pain et domingo qui est
fou c'est cinq ici peut-être poussé 5
c'était c'est jamais facile à voir mais
bon tour un qui gagne la pièce aussi
parce que ses protégés par la tour et
que surtout reprend b4 maintenant de
toute façon on reprend bk 3 prend la
main ça gagne et donc c'est nous qui
gagne encore une partie bon là c'est un
peu sur missclick j'ai envie de dire
donc ça retourne sur cavalière 3g trois
fous j'ai 2
donc ça va ressembler à une enfin une
grünfeld avec un temps de plus et puis
finalement ça fait le truc avec double
enquête au on joue avec ses 4 après
prise et sûrement il ya voir ces quatre
tôt ou tard ça va continuer avec ses
cadres voilà maintenant du coup il y
avait cette grosse activité avec les
deux filles en quête au je vous disais
en début de de retransmission que c'est
la position que j'avais part
personnellement parfois avec les noirs
et que j'avais beaucoup de mal à jouer
du tour c'est un cavalier c5
je trouve ça assez désagréable à jouer
avec les noirs l'accueil des quatre
c'est bien joué ce que sur qu'il prend
dame prend la dame rentrant des cas
peut-être affaire qu'elle va faire qui
les prend et d'amd calmy rey encore
cavaliers apsys pour le moment donc tour
c'est en premier je déteste jouer ça
avec les noirs perso après
c'est pas forcément grand chose mais
c'est ultra pénible et il faut savoir
rien faire et là c'est déjà
problématique parce qu'il ya ces six qui
peut rester en l'air dans pas mal de
variantes sur cavalière si je pense
cavaliers prendre prise prise prise et à
ses six qui reste en l'air donc elle
fait f6 et tour des uns et la les noirs
sont déjà moins bien forcément ces
grosses concessions
les pièces les blancs qui sont bien
placés hockey québec a très bien joué
parce qu'elle protège ici en risque
alors juste un coup comme à trois dames
3 bien jouer découvre sur la dame et du
coup il peut même heure des idées avec
deux pions aux 6 en ligne de mire genre
cavaliers quelque part ok mais là ce
petit fou prend elle veut faire dame
prend aussi ses intermédiaires et bien
jouer et là il ya peut-être du cavalier
des cinq qui est possible qui a l'air
ultra pénible qui a aidé 5 en cavale et
prend fou prend il ya le problème du
cloud âge ça je crois que c'est moi mes
preuves puisqu'elle veut qu'à y prend b4
et tout reprend ses six ya la dame qui a
attaqué il ya tout qui attaquaient est
non mais c'est dur à jouer ses positions
là il ya cavaliers prend des cats je
suppose et fou prend ses six ça gagne
une pièce ou cac et prend b6 mais
qu'elle prend des capteurs sagan il faut
cesser je sais pas mais bon cavalier là
ça gagne la tour s'est vite ouais nan
mais ya tout qui tombe à barika et prend
des 5 vous prend des 5 et poker juste
faire qu'il prend des cinq classes et
une pièce un prix c'est un prix c'est un
manque est pressée 8 c'est encore mieux
bon après c'est une question de choix
elle a choisi le coup plus fort qui est
français qu'il nie carrément une tour ça
fait plus neuf
et là ça devient très difficile dans la
tête de continuer parce que l'on sait
que le match est perdu il reste 17
minutes de jeu et franchement c'est dur
c'est dur c'est dur c'est dur pour pour
zaton spire le match est perdu c'est un
peu la correctionnelle
c'est un peu
c'est un peu la correctionnelle c'est
dommage parce que parce que parce que
sur le contenu comme je disais elle
n'était pas si loin elle manque juste un
peu de vitesse après voilà c'est le
blitz on le dit on le répète jouer vite
ça fait partie du truc ça fait partie du
jeu c'est limité dans le temps donc
c'est un peu l'objectif si kosteniuk
réfléchissez plus elle jouerait mieux
aussi
mais elle gère mieux son temps du coup
comme elle est plus forte elle peut
mieux gérer son temps ouais voilà c'est
un peu c'est la vie c'est comme ça touré
huit bons
comment ça va jouer j'ai un peu lâché la
partie honnêtement mais en a qui a du
mal à elles réfléchissent et jusque elle
arrive fluvial yaris eu à mon avis elle
voit plus rien à mon avis elle a le truc
d' aveuglement ya pas de suisse dames
prend des un es fou prend 1,5 ici ok il
ya peut-être dû contre eux avec ses 6 et
surtout ses 8 ok c'est pas idiot ce
qu'elle a fait j'imagine que son idée
c'est sur faut prendre lui faire c'est
cissé quand le fourmillant s'est vite
avec du tour des huit échecs et mat
donc c'est plutôt bien joué mais bon une
nouvelle fois c'est juste c'est juste
trop lent 2 3 c'est bien jouer sa menace
ici et ça avoue l'échangé les fous ah
non elle se balade elle se balade
lacoste et duke c'est la ballade key c4
ok sa lutte encore sa lutte encore a
bien joué le coup qu'il y en avait cinq
avaient changé les dames
voilà une bonne série de coups avec les
blancs la tour d2 surtout provoqué des
six qui est décisif gagné une pièce je
crois mais mon cas et prendre trois
gagnants un pion c'est déjà pas mal
cette quête des six gagne pas du tout
une pièce parce qu'on a pas assez
difficile quand c'est pas vos parties en
bullet devoir séduire dont auront des
cinq sa tour d'essai doit elle trouve du
contre elle perdrait gagne perd 2
maintenant tout reprend à 7 elle
récupère ça il va falloir voir comment
elle se débrouille avec son fou et sa
tour alors elle vient et que font des
cinq tours price à 3,8 ranger sa toile
va récupérer des pions lacoste est nu
qui a du mal à colmater ses pions faut
peut-être qu'elle fasse f5 tour fz38
pourpre angers7
et sauver hhk ce n'est peut-être pas
forcément utile parce que ça fait un
cadeau d'un coup mais peu importe peu
importe ok maintenant il peut envoyer h
elle va remettre la tour b 7 si elle
peut certes pas l'impression kosteniuk
de toute façon est tellement ok pour
preuve 3 way serait tellement plus plus
fort tendu la 3g 8 et avaler c'est fini
c'est un cavalier à tanger un élan le
roi qui arrive pas à monter car les f3
et il va y avoir tout reprend g3 non
elle n'y arrive pas encore tomber un à
leroy qui est complètement bloquée et
elle tombait c'est dommage elle était
bien revenue dans la partie mais une
nouvelle fois c'est trop juste
donc c'est reparti ok la normale ont des
trois ou quatre c'est la réputation
comme quoi cavaliers froid sur calais 3
f 5 à jouer mais ça va juste transposer
dans un stonewall kosteniuk qui à +10
maintenant avec 12 minutes à jouer c'est
quasiment même terminé même en cas de
déconnexion même en cas de déconnexion
c'est quasi terminé à 10 points d'écart
et c'est un match qui aura été
intéressant mais qui aura pas qui aura
pas vraiment fait vibrer en termes de en
terme de suspense
l'écart de niveau était était trop fort
et donc qu'elle jouera contre daniele
ans ce sera un match intéressant
danielian qui a finalement un peu le
même style que hatton ski rhin a joué
bien ses positions car elle vous fallait
défendre mais
les jouets peut-être mieux les attentes
ce qui en tout cas quand elle était mal
autant elle craquait pas danielian face
à langnau
alors est-ce que c'est l'agglo qui était
pas au top ou est-ce que ces derniers
l'ayant qui est très forte on aura la
réponse pour les dents dans la
demi-finale alors là elle va tenter
d'amasser 1 je pense pour essayer d'en
elle va essayer d'y enfermer le fou mon
comme ça mais elle va essayer dû en
fermer le fou elle va faire dame c'est
un manant mais il y aura des cas très
poussées 3 donc y aura le temps de le
sauver
quatre cavaliers 4 faut bouger à 3 way
ça va encore être un fou qui va
disparaître
ça t'inspire qui boit le calice jusqu'à
la lie il y avait eu six cavaliers aussi
ce doit vraiment le calice jusqu'à la
lie le fou en plus entre 3 et protégés
ok mais ça c'est un bon intermédiaire
qui on prend bien fou prend 1,3 quèsaco
senuc elle avait raté
cependant la position reste très
difficile pour les noirs et quand même
une qualité de moins la tête dam des
deux l'a très bien joué bien joué en bus
date c'est pas des coups faciles ça et
on sait 3 ou tour ces quatre mêmes tours
d un tour ces trois à tour ces trois et
qui avait lieu 4 quoique puis on prend
fou prendre à me prendre ya rien à tour
ces trois ici c'est fini tout reprend
détroit le pion détroit disparaissez
mort un plus à force les échanges ne
peut pas éviter les échanges les
échanges massif et donc ça fait qualité
de plus le jouet f4 ici auxquels fait
fébé quatre tours dès 8 heures à jouer
quatre maintenant elle va s'ouvrir le
fou zaton ce qui re qui abandonnent et
ça fait plus 11 maintenant +11 et il
reste dix minutes à jouer donc le match
est mathématiquement terminée pour le
moment on nous écrit en dessous qui a
jamais eu un joueur qui a remporté
toutes les parties 2 1 + 1
et kosteniuk qui après dix minutes de
jeu après 20 minutes de jeu mène sur le
score de 6-0 donc admis son premier set
elle est allée à trois victoires du nh90
donc alors qu'amélie f4 d'avoir g4
avancer donc
faire tourner un oeil à voir food et
deux non food est vraiment fou des
doigts elle peut faire elle fait à 3
elle veut éviter un truc est fou des six
volets seront invités kébé 4 qui était
pénible cavale yeux de a une nouvelle
fois ça se passe pas très bien pour les
blancs quoi que l attaque des cadres
j'ai l'impression qu'elle s'est
tellement affaiblie de partout que ça me
paraît difficile à jouer en bullet cette
histoire il ya b3 qui peut être fragile
il ya des trois qui peut être fragile
des cats est bien protégé le fou qui est
toujours pas sorti
peut-être faut se débarrasser du fou de
cases blanches est barrée avec le foie
angers 5 histoire d'un peu bougé des
pièces ce qu'il faut se développer aux
échecs 1 quand même mais avait tout
reprend en main et d'apprendre des trois
là dessus d'où l'idée de fougue et de
fou prend fou prend donc là il ya tout
reprendre un qui menace ricco peut-être
prendre 1 800 cavaliers à tour programme
prend b3 end of the story auquel le voit
pas on va jouer ce qu'ils sont fatigués
va-t-on dire qu'il a vu juste derrière
le petit chipeau je crois qu'il marchait
je suis pas sûr ok là ça va encore
d'anne decis damage du fairway f1 pépère
le chat il n'y a rien qu'on ya un fond
et de y'a rien il y aura rien là y aura
rien tu peux être tranquille ça ça fait
peur ça fait peur aux mouches à la lépi
peu il peut rien y avoir quelle tu peux
faire g5 et d'un proche 5 ou qu'elles
provoquaient faut quand même faire gaffe
de ne pas se prendre un cavalier angers
4 un jour mais pour le moment le
cavalier n'y arrive pas
ok dameuse s'inquiète sur zéro menace
d'un e 2 c'était pas le coup le plus
inspiré sa paire un pion en un est
obligé de refaire dames 1 dames g5 la
dame qui vient attaquer sac avec cinq
sacres ehpad menace une nouvelle fois
mais ça protège g4 latéralement
donc ça c'est pas mal bon le roi blanc
qui passe si mal en réalité mais les
pièces blanches qui ont perdu leurs
harmonies et maintenant il ya g4 qui
tombe d'un g4 qui tombe à j-4 qui aurait
pu tomber noah c'est joli ça oh ça
c'était beau elle a méthodiquement lever
toutes les cases de la tour sur la
quatrième elle a fait tomber donc ça
nous fait 7 0 dans la section bullet
il reste six minutes à jouer à ça
commence à faire très cher là ça fait 19
sept
heureusement que qu'elle n'a pas coulé
avant donc
maintenant ça va rejouer avec grand
roque c'est peut-être finalement dans
ces scandinaves qu'elle a eu les
meilleures positions en bullet that i'm
still here allez peut-être un petit coup
de cavaliers des cinq ici et surtout
prend on reprend de ses balais pour me
faire plaisir et gagner une seconde une
créature prend de sétif et ours et 8 à
la scandinave c'est quand même une
valeur sûre à l'essai prend et voilà
c'est bien ça à tour ses 8 allée à les
dames à 5 et ours et 8 peut-être pour
ces huit en premier quand même parce que
là le cavalier a le temps de partir du
coup on a perdu un tempo et ça laisse
froid b2 b3 à b2 et b6 est fou des deux
machin va peut-être on a perdu un tempo
dans le dans le truc c'est que je
pensais la même position avec le temps
de prendre un b3 en c3 mais bon peu
importe
allez c'est pas mal fou les deux tours
c'est 6 peut-être aller tour c63 17 pour
ses 8 après 17 tours ces six tours ces
huit tours b six banques essaient de se
créer du jeu allez un p'tit coup de
tours ces six là ok sur h5 g5 à elle
veut faire tout rage cette courageuse
huit meilleurs atours h3 c'est chose
faite
key biscayne c4 ça c'est bien et elle
peut peut-être rebondir par les toura je
suis ton bien colmaté là bas salat mon
avis elle peut la gagner
le cavalier va venir dans ses cales ckt
car il ya quatre oui pas mal comme ça le
foot va repartir vers à et peut repartir
anciens et on n'arrive pas à gagner ses
trois hayatou reprend ces trois noms non
t'as pas le droit de pas voir ça au nom
elles ont peu plus et on peut plus elle
a bien manoeuvré elle manoeuvre bien
elle joue encore bien aux échecs en main
d'oeuvre et tout ça mais elle voit plus
rien elle doit avoir le même truc que
j'ai parfois quand je joue c'est que tu
ta ta ta ta plus la vision bon elle
réussit quand même à taper le pion pas
vraiment elle doit plus avoir la vision
du jeu
malheureusement ça tu peux rien y faire
quand tu quand tu regardes l'échiquier
que tu vois plus rien tu peux rien c'est
triste mais c'est comme ça elle était
bien la pendule elle était bien partout
mais doit plus rien voir juste juste
aloi plus elle voit plus un est ce que
tu peux y faire quand ça marche plus ça
marche plus un
la tour prend 1,6 maintenant qu'il va
arriver peut-être le faire pour ces cinq
à thouarcé 5
ok faut prendre 5 vous prendrez 4
fallait peut-être tentés tourbe et 5 ou
quelque chose mais là c'est mort
le fou qui est trop fort le pion qui va
nulle part c'est celui-là qui va tomber
c'est lui qui va à dame et ses morts
ok c'est pas sûr que si ça gagne c'est 4
à saint louis mairet 5 s'est perdue cc3
fallait très fallait tenter wife qu'à
trois des cinq renonce à perdre et quand
même et là il ya 3 c3 droit et dans le
carré et ça fait encore un point de plus
pour kosteniuk mais bon là c'est cadeau
sur cadeau un peu plus à la lier plus
aller plus dans le match là je pense que
tu tu peux arrêter tu peut l'arrêter à
la juste plus d'énergie à la plus de
peps à la plus rien non mais c'est la
vie c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça faut faire forfait non
mais bon c'est dur mais ce serait pas
mal que qui est quelqu'un qui viennent
d'apprendre qu'ils ont tué chaos tu ne
peux plus jouer coiffe un fou l'arbitré
vient conter tu ne vois plus une
tactique et j'ai pas il te montre une
position et il te dis oui comment sauver
la pièce et puis tu trouves pas et ils
te dis bon le match est arrêté
ko technique tu as perdu que la ccsa un
cas peut-être plus on prend le cadre
juste et sûr cavale epr en france et 4
et xhaka c'est qu'elle s'inquiétait des
quatre échecs maintenant probablement ou
qu'il prend 2,5 et prend 1,5
saha grand roque donc à elle s'en tire à
bon compte encore zaton skhira rockhal
son sirh sans être perdante quand même
ce qui est extraordinaire elle n'était
pas loin de tout cas ça va changer après
roy prend des deux fous prend 1,4 ou
prou 5-fu prend un chien tout reprend h
1 mais ça va en fait pour auquel surtout
pas faire tour intermédiaire de
racailles trois échecs
donc tu n'as pas de bons intermédiaires
et maintenant elle à la tour ayew manque
un temps pour arriver sur f7 au kg 6 3/4
froid e61 kefu b8 bien jouer aller pour
sauver l'honneur
ok retour à 8 fou prend fou prend aller
là elle s'en est quand même super bien
tiré je pense que ses pions sont super
forts
la finale a une bonne tête la finale est
une très bonne tête
allez il faut la gagner celle-là kirwa
c3 stabilise autour f3 oui bien joué
elle veut faire ou à ses 5 s'est mieux
jouer encore au keops et 5 pts et 3 c
s'inquiétait je sais pas parce qu'à
tours d2 mais les pions les pions sont
pas liées de l'autre côté ça va assez
assez c'est hyper menaçant roi b5
maintenant bk 3b ici ça avance à lire
wah wah web et 4 sa prise prise roi b6
c'est dommage de pas avoir mis laurent b
6 ok c'est bien elle va devoir mettre la
cour en g3 maintenant il ya trois b 6 ok
c'est très bien ça calais avant ses
pions d'une rangée aller à la chasse le
roi a sur le pouf et b5 voilà c'est bien
ok c'est encore un échec c'est bien tu
as sur le coup maintenant c'est 7 et
tout reprend h3 qui fait dame
ah bon elle aurait pu le faire avant
elle aurait pu faire ces huit dames n'en
était pas forcément les premières
forcément les bonnes décisions mais ok
ça tu vas gagner quand même
j'ai l'impression que tout est dur à
gagner pour atteindre ce qui rend ce
moment c'est terrible c'est terrible gx
et terry parce qu'il m'arrive d'avoir le
même problème et que tout soit dur à
gagner pour moi mais elle va y arriver
ça arrive des fois tu craques et auquel
elle sauve l'honneur et elle finit pas
sur une bulle en bulle est ça aurait pu
être la première le premier joueur
premiers joueurs joueuses à faire fanni
en bullet et c'est pas le cas ça fait
quand même plaisir à la sauver l'honneur
elle en a gagné une en bullet c'est
quand même sympa et donc score final 20
à 8
bon c'est en cinq plus un début de match
à la whey un peu vendanger en 3 + 1
finalement elle est un peu revenu dans
le match et on a senti qu'elle était
moins rapide et elle finit par perdre en
bullet sur un gros score mais mais la
différence de niveau était clair moins
rapide moins il ya eu tant plus été dur
du coup les mecs ce qu'on va faire c'est
que je voulais c'est trois quatre
minutes avec notre petite pub et après
je vous mettrai en raid sur la chaîne
officielle de duchess points comme si
vous souhaitez voir les interviews des
joueurs
nous on se retrouve demain soir pour le
match de ce pitch est junior à partir de
18 heures je vous remercie à tous
d'avoir suivi
merci beaucoup et on se dit à demain et
jeudi vendredi dans les deux gros
matches avec fab et mvl chao tout le
monde
[Musique]